Hmm.
Hey everybody,
this episode of Joe Rogan experience is
brought to you by stamps.com stamps.com
is a service that we, we know
very well because, uh, in fact,
Brian uses it. Tom Segura and
Christina Palicki use it. Uh,
many people we know have used stamps.com
to send things through the mail where
you would ordinarily have
to go to the post office,
get your shit weighed out, get, you know,
paid different prices for different
things. So they have to like,
they have to measure everything and
figure out how much you owe them.
And you have to wait in line behind a
bunch of other people that are doing the
same thing. You could do all that stuff
at home naked. You don't have to be there.
You don't have to be looking
at the screen. You know,
you could make funny faces
when you put the things on it.
You can be really rude to yourself.
You can do whatever you want.
And with stamps.com they allow you to
do this in the privacy of your own home
and save money.
You can print u s postal stamps,
actual real postage on your home computer.
It's amazing.
It's super easy to do.
And if you go to the old timey microphone
in the upper right hand corner of
stamps.com type in the offer code,
the Promo Code j r e and
get this no risk trial.
It's $110 bonus offer and includes a
digital scale and up to $55 in free
postage.
You don't have to do anything else,
you don't have to go to the post office,
you print everything at home.
The postman comes like he normally does.
Do you hand them the
packages and you're done.
It cuts many steps out of the process.
It's a beautiful thing. And again,
the offer code is j r e
for your $110 bonus offer,
no risk trial and includes a digital
scale and up to $55 in free postage.
So go to stamps.com before you do
anything typed in j r e at the old school,
the microphone in the
upper right hand corner,
that stamps.com and enter j r e were also
brought to you by audible.com audible
is the leading source of audio
entertainment on the Internet and a,
uh, a website that I've been using
for a long time. They're amazing.
They have so many different titles
over 150,000 other titles. They have,
you know, audio books and
podcasts and stand up comedy.
And if you go to audible.com
forward slash Joe,
you will get one free audio book
and 30 free days of audible service.
Amazing books, amazing
comedy content. It's just,
it's really just a fantastic resource
for getting shit online that a,
you would ordinarily have to read
yourself. You know, reading is fun,
but sometimes you want to hear other
people read. Great for driving to work to,
if you have a, you know, if
you're in traffic you're just,
might as well read a book while you're
in traffic and they're a cool company and
they've,
they've supported standup comedy for
a long time and I just think they're
fantastic. And also if you have
the, if you use the kindle HD fire,
they have this amazing new technology
called whisper sync and what whisper sync
is,
it works on both your,
your kindle and it also works with audible
and it picks up where you leave off.
And what that means is you could
buy the book and read it like a,
if you're sitting in bed at night
and then when you go to bed he, it,
it marks down where you are.
You get in the car and the, the,
the podcast or rather the audio version
of that book will pick up exactly where
you left off reading. It's
amazing. It's such a cool idea.
So you read and then when you're
done reading, you shut it off.
You get in your car and the actor reading
the shit picks up where you left off.
This is a beautiful world we live in.
I'm so happy about it.
I'm so happy about all this fucking cool
technology that's happening and things
like this.
Whisper sync is just a perfect example
of someone just figuring out how to make
this even cooler.
audible.com forward slash Joe,
get yourself a free audio book
and 33 Days off audible surfing.
You got to get the Xbox Joe
[inaudible] control with your voice.
Like I'm just going to his TV too much.
Great. Uh, on a.com is our last sponsor.
Go to o, n. N. I. T. Check everything
out if you haven't been there in a while.
There's a lot of new supplements
like including digestive tech,
digestive enzymes that help your body
process nutrients more efficiently and
effectively. Um, all kinds of cool shit.
Alpha brain and new mood and testosterone
boosting supplements that actually do
work. Go to [inaudible]
dot com use the code name,
Rogan and save 10% off any
and all supplements. How do
I say your last name? Dude?
Diverse. Get up to the [inaudible].
All right. Phil dimmers is here.
He's going to talk to us. We're going
to learn some shit. We're going to,
we're going to get to the bottom of
some things. Phil knows Wallace's
the Joe Rogan experience.
Hey,
Joe Rogan podcast by night.
So the young man and targets you
right now filled dimmers. Um, he,
I heard about you on Twitter,
on the Internet.
People were contacting me about your,
uh,
your situation where you, um,
you're an animal trainer, right?
I Wa I was an animal or an animal trainer.
Why don't you tell us your story,
tell us what,
what got you to this point of controversy
or that could take a while. Like how,
where do you want to delve
wherever it's interesting shit. Uh,
well off the hop, let's just talk about
how I became an animal trainer. Okay.
I'm 22 years old,
actually went to school for
a broadcast engineering. Um,
you know, I want, I had aspirations of
recording bands and touring with bands,
whatever it be, uh, as any confused
22 year old punk boy would be.
And then sure as Shit one day at my
dad and I were cruising around and he's
given me the old, you got to
get a job son. I'm like, Shit,
because I paid a lot of
money from education,
which ultimately became a free
download about six months later.
Like we're talking 2000, right. So and uh,
saw an article in the paper you want to
be a marine mammal trainers assistant.
And I thought that's,
that sounds like a great job.
I can scrub buckets or do whatever it
is to the people who are training these
animals, but I didn't think
I could get the job. Um,
applied for the Gig and uh, you
know, what size boots do you wear?
Boom nine got this job. And I wasn't,
you know, getting that marine mammals,
trainers, assistant job wasn't, you
know, you're going to go scrub buckets,
everything. I mean there were obviously
that it encompassed all of that,
but I sort of training animals really
quickly. Like right off the hop,
right off the hop.
They're teaching you how to do it and
they're teaching her how to do it.
You know. Now is there a science to
train these things or is there, there's,
they're like,
like nice methods or more cruel methods.
Cause I've heard of some of the masses
that you use to train orchids as kind of
disturbing,
you know,
they lock them in pens together and get
them really tightly grouped up where
they can't do anything and they don't
feed them unless they do their tricks.
Yeah. That that exists in just about
every application of animal training,
but that's not the perspective that you
exercise or that they train you when
they train you to train animals.
It's about positive reinforcement.
So if an animal does something that's
a desired behavior for instance,
you reward them for that in that there's
the subtle nuances of if they're not
doing what it is you're asking, you
don't reward them. So that's where,
that's where the, you know, the, and then
there's negative punishment. I mean there,
there is all of that, all of that
existed in training historically.
But trainers now and the art of
training of training animals,
it's more positive reinforcement based.
So you learn all of that off the hop.
But at the end of the day there's one,
there's one variable and that's fish.
So it's either reinforcement
or ultimately deprivation.
And it was all things that you
learn and are effective tools.
So you need both. You should
train like a, an aura,
an Orca,
you develop a relationship with the orcas,
the orcas learn really quickly,
I want to do this because I'm
being reinforced for doing. So.
It's a simple as that. That's,
so you sort of run with that,
you develop that language. There
becomes a, an understanding between,
especially over the years as you
grow this, this relationship,
the animals know and the animals,
the animals I work with every one of them.
I'd never met a single animal that I
wasn't incredibly like good natured,
just really good and
really wanted to please.
So it's not very difficult
to train an Orca,
especially when applying
the positive reinforcement.
So if that's the case and how
does it happen that you, you,
you hear stories about like these animals
being corralled up in small cages with
or small pens with a bunch of them like
stuck right next to each other and how
they deprive them of food for punishment.
Like is that bullshit? No, no,
that's absolutely not bullshit.
That's a, how does that happen?
I think what we're talking about is
something that happened a lot like a long
time ago. Rather it is what does system
amalgamated or turned into, you know, the,
the more of the positive reinforcement
aspect. But when you look at that, you're,
you're trying to suggest the negative
reinforcement aspect of it where hey
you're, you're being bad, so I'm
going to shove you over here.
This would be more of a circumstance
where you can't positively reinforce an
animal for doing something because they're
not doing anything that is desired by
design of the positive reinforcement
technique. So whatever's going on here,
you're avoiding inadvertently by avoiding,
you're not rewarding,
you're not feeding your withholding food.
So this is a lot of talk
and hold on a second.
This is a lot of talk to try
to answer one simple question.
Why did they put them in a pen like
squished all next to each other?
I'm really confused.
While in what situation would they be?
I mean they had at any fun. So are
you saying they don't do that anymore?
That's because what I've
read about them treating,
like one of the big things that people
were complaining about was that they
would pack all these animals into these
pens and put them next to each other in
these tanks and they really had no room
to move and they want it biting each
other sometimes. Oh, tiny tanks.
I mean all facilities have different
sized tanks or options to mix or divide
animals or whatever.
So,
and that they would deprive them of food
if you are depriving the animal of food,
that would work in the sense that if you
had animals in one environment and you
want them to go in another, a place
where the animal didn't want to go,
you can't reinforce that animal if
it's not going through that gate.
So the idea is you're going to try to
coax that animal through positive sort of
short, short steps. You know these,
these approximations and you reinforce
each approximation. Eventually they go in,
you're reinforcing them, you're giving
them that reward for going through,
but if they're not going through, you
can't reinforce him. So it's actually,
it's deprivation in that sense.
What does it feel like to train
something that you know is probably
misunderstood and really smart
like a killer whale or an Orca?
They're probably pretty misunderstood by
most people, don't you think? Absolutely.
100% there are super intelligent
creatures, right? Like it's hard to it.
I don't like to,
it's hard to call them an animal just
because you know there's definition,
whatever that is of animal and there's
a stark contrast between humans and
animals in whatever it is.
Whatever that definition is.
When it comes to [inaudible]
and intelligent beings,
there's no contrast between humans and,
and I want to say animals
as a whole because they have
best interests. They have,
you know,
they have objectives.
I'm not sure that there is conscious
of those objectives. Maybe they are.
How do we know?
Well we know about brain size and we
know about how much activity's going on.
And I see, I see what you're saying to
a certain extent about some animals,
but looking at rats eyes and tell me
he's like thinking about poetry. Okay.
Maybe his looking at dolphins
eyes and there's a big difference.
There's a big difference between making
eye contact with the marine mammal.
There's something weird about them.
They're very smart. They're very smart.
They're very smart in a weird way. Like
where it's like what's going on in there?
Like that seems like almost
like a person in a weird outfit.
Spiritual way for sure.
Is that the most fucked up aspect
about places where they
have them in tanks?
Cause it seems to me that that's
like we're going to watch slavery,
we're going to watch slavery
of an animal that we don't,
we don't understand what they're saying.
So we think it's okay
to just lock them up.
That's a perspective that
your capable of exercising.
But when people are sitting there in
front of their TV and they watch that
jingle come on or whatever and you know,
seaworld jingle where I led a candidate
jingle, hey, that's fun. They go there,
they blocked out a lot of the things.
They paid a lot of money to be there.
They're there to be entertained,
that there to be happy.
They shut their brains off
to a lot of things. You know,
maybe there's an inclination for a
second that's messed up right there,
but I think that they,
at the end of the day,
they're looking to be entertained and
they get that music and the splish splash.
You got wet. Hey, I'm happy. I'm
going home. Happy my kids happy.
We'll do something weird about
wanting animals to do our bidding.
There's something weird
about those dog shows.
Those dog shows aren't just
about how cute your dog is.
Those dog shows us about your dog being
just on fucking point listening to you
every step of the way.
Being completely trained stopped
when you stopped prancing.
When you tell it to prance,
all that stupid shit.
That doesn't mean anything like bears
bouncing a fucking ball on the tip of
their nose.
That doesn't mean anything either,
but if you can get me a band that can
ride a bike and bounce a ball up on his
head,
I'm going to make you a millionaire is
a bunch of assholes out there that want
to see this stupid fucking bear, do some
shit that any normal person can do. It's,
it's weird, right? It's an affinity for,
for almost for that dominance to assert
your dominance on something and people
do it to humans every single day as
well. But certainly with animals, when,
I mean animals don't speak English,
I don't speak any other
language for that matter,
but they do speak their own and
they can't express to us like, Hey,
like maybe let me Outta here.
Well,
they're speaking the language and
that's something that is really hard for
people to understand.
There's a difference between some sounds
that animals make that would indicate
that there's some sort of communication
going on and a pure language. Dolphins,
whales, Orcas, they have
a language like this.
It's not as small as a few grunts and
it's so complex and weird and it's so
sound based, we can't
even decipher it. We,
we have ideas that they're saying
the same thing, but there's dialects.
They're from different areas where they
do it like it's so complex that it's
like our human language just we don't
understand it and we can't crack it.
So because of that,
because we can't hear their screams,
we just put them in these fucking tanks.
It's really dark because we don't consider
them to be intelligent because they
can't manipulate things with their
fingers because they can't build housing.
Let's just walk out. They can't
walk out. They can't get out there,
but in their world and the world of
the ocean, you don't need thumbs.
He don't need any of that.
In fact,
we would be like terribly designed for
the ocean if we were forced to become
marine animals and things would change
radically and quickly. All right.
The placement of our air hole
is a fucking stupid place.
The way your mouth works, a stupid, you
can't really close it. Good can be fat.
He can't be fat. Can't be lazy.
You can't be lazy. You got to move
24 hours a day. You barely, you don't
even really sleep right. Well they,
they sleep while they're in motion.
You almost wonder if just the
pure instinct to survive and,
and maybe limiting oneself language or
species language isn't more genius than
having such an elaborate language.
Cause you almost wonder if we don't
communicate as effectively as we could
because we know too many
damn words. Like, you know,
how much language is expressed and how,
how you see each other and how we,
you know,
well then all the things that we've
invented that we have to name and then the
interaction of those things
in places that we've invented,
like cities and airplanes and cars,
all those things that we've invented.
I'll take on a whole new school
of vocabulary on their own. Yeah.
It's fucking ridiculous. John Lennon said
like, imagine a world with no borders,
no nothing.
And I think he's imagining the land of
the Orca is really know what they say
Lando, but essentially he's
envisioning an ocean. Yeah.
But he also married Yoko Ono. That's,
it was a silly bitch. You know,
a lot of people are big John Lennon fans.
They don't want to miss that.
But come on son,
you got to look at everything that
guy says with a grain of salt.
I showed my girlfriend like a
video of Yoko Ono. She's like,
I didn't even know Yoko Ono does that.
The whole like all this screaming.
She's like, oh, what's this amount?
That's Yoko Ono. Strange. Um, yeah,
that's not good. But the sound
of Orcas is probably, you know,
for a lot of people it sounds like Yoko
ono underwater. It's pretty easy go.
Ironically. You know, it's kind of does
maybe John Lennon was, was onto something.
He was, I think he just, he had a weakness
there. It was. We all have weakness. Yeah.
Um,
so like,
do you think that there's gonna come a
point in time where they will be able to
solve and doll decipher dolphin language
and realize like what you're doing is
imprisoning humans?
They're there.
It's essentially just as bad as if
we found a group of blue people.
They were people, but they
were blue. Put them in a cage.
We couldn't understand a word they said.
They would talk like dolphins, like
make crazy noises that we couldn't
decipher but clearly talking to each other
and we just decided to put them in blue
people world. You'd be rich quick. Yeah,
I mean we would do that.
Of course that would be a little harder
to sell because they look closer to us
because of fingers and shit.
But if you could just realize that a
dolphin is probably just like the Ma,
the mind of a person
or maybe even weirder,
maybe even more intense and a lot
of ways this cerebral, emotional,
more emotional. They're the basis of
their language and their and their being.
They're just so such a social animal
and they have such like long and deep
social structure, social
dynamics, family bonds,
so deep that at the end of
the day it's like these guys,
you almost have to wonder if they're more
by far more intelligent and more like
sympathetic than we are because that's
where we lack is were were dicks.
They're not dicks.
One of the interesting things is that
dolphins don't really kill people except
for in captivity. And I've read
something online, somebody wrote,
but it turned out to be total bullshit.
But it was kind of funny that a guy said
that dolphins used to kill people up
until World War II because
in World War II, the fighter
pilots started using, not dolphins,
but orcas started using a Orca as,
as target practice. And the
orcas realize, all right,
we'd better not fuck with people.
They got the under.
So word got out and now they don't kill
people anymore. It sounds hilarious. Uh,
but it turned out to be bullshit.
But it's fascinating. If it was true,
but they're that smart did, the point
is like they actually could do that.
If they found out that
people were shooting people,
they would probably tell each other.
They'd be like, hey man, you hear that?
That sounds,
eh,
dive, go under the, um, I mean, it's,
the relationship that we have with them
is very bizarre and we're going to be
incredibly embarrassed if we find
out what they're actually saying.
One day we realize what we've done.
All these people go into slave world.
You're going to slave world,
you're going to watch slaves do flips.
I've been privy to like probably some
messages that I know would be beating the
shit out of me even more than the shit
kicking I've already taken since having
left that Gig. So yeah.
What do you mean? Well,
the idea that if you're listening to it,
if we decipher what the dolphins sang,
I mean I've had to do some,
I've,
I've had to do some things
with dolphins like you know,
let's speak hypothetically just for a
second. Okay. On my lawyer's advice.
So let's assume that a green dolphin
comes in and let's call it an elderly
dolphin.
A real old male dolphin comes in,
so he's just been captured via Jospin
capture, just been captured, who knows,
a month before he was out in the wild his
whole life, his whole life and old man,
wise, old man comes in with a group of
about six, seven others, mostly young,
really aesthetically pleasing animals.
And this one just is not prepared
to stomach the life of captivity.
And so what do you resort to? You
start force feeding them, right.
So again, just hypothetically dropping a
pool, the water's down to nothing. Again.
Shit, ton of dolphins green
so they're not trained. They,
they're swimming around that crazy
and you're having to go down there,
grab a towel wrapped around its rostrum
which is the end of their nose there.
That face, open it up and start cramming
like frozen fish in there. Oh my God.
What message do you think that Dolphin
was probably trying to tell me?
So imagine if I could like,
I just imagine a point like,
just to go back to what you said
about decipher the language,
I can't imagine what I'd be processing,
you know, if like if they were,
if they were able to communicate on a,
a language to language
understanding with humans. Yeah.
That's dark shit and be tough.
Yeah. Now that's part of your life.
I mean that was part of my life, but
that's like everybody does it. If you're,
if you're,
if you're a trainer like that is
something that you're going to have to do
something that's not even the worst of
days. That's just part of your life.
You like part of your
life is he'd take a towel,
you wrapping around the dolphins face,
you open it up and you stuff frozen
fish in there. Try to keep my life,
start injecting them right in the back
injections and no one ever says, hey,
maybe we should let this guy go. Well,
when you're in Niagara Falls, Canada,
there's really nowhere that
you can let them go. I mean,
I'm not really specific animals.
The animals we brought in
were from the Black Sea.
Where's the Black Sea in Russia? Russia's
where there's a lot of trade in Russia.
I mean they've as we speak,
have some wild caught or cause that they
caught in the last like month or two
and they're two of the two of which in
fact are being sent to soap or to Moscow
to be on display during the Sochi
Olympics. Wow. Fuck. Wild caught. Yeah.
Horrible mood and that. Those are slaves.
Those are slaves. They really are.
They're slaves that will do tricks that
have to do tricks if they want to live.
I mean, I don't want to say if
they want to live, but yeah,
that's what it boils down to. You're,
you're tapping into their survival mode.
You read this thing about workers that
their cerebral cortex is 40% larger than
a human beings. Like that's something's
going on in there. You know what,
whether it's what we like to think of
his consciousness or whether it's some
sort of an alternate state that they
only can appreciate because they live
underwater,
but whatever it is,
there's talent once and it seems really
fucking cruel and shortsighted that we
locked them up. There's a scene in black
fish where you see a group of boat,
a pot of about five orcas, six orchids.
They're hunting a seal and in it,
this woman named Lori Marino
who's a neuroscientist,
she's saying it's
conceivable or what we've,
what we've come to learn is that they're
able to exercise a mind as as one.
It's a singular consciousness between
the group it and in the scene,
the seals sitting on a,
on a little ice flow,
a little tiny ice pad that orcas come in
all five and simultaneously a boom like
this dunk,
this side of the iceberg and then the
other and then the wave sort of goes over
and they shoot the seal over and then
you're talking some serious intelligence
when you start talking
collective conscious and as
a, as a singular conscious,
now you're talking.
So that's some deep shit right there.
They plan that out in a way that a
lot of people would never figure out
simultaneously as one. And it, it appears
as though one is leading the show,
the restaurant's system shut down
and they're just going in as a,
as like an army of one. It's, yeah,
and they're communicating
while they're doing this,
they're organizing this and communicating
it that they understand that I had to
shut it off,
man.
I had to shut it off as soon as they
were talking about their dorsal fins
collapsing because they don't use them
because they're not out there fucking
using them in swimming. And
they're just upright. So I mean,
all that weight of that cartilage
is just going to, over time,
it's going to peel that sucker. Right?
Fucked up. I used to scratch candy.
We had a big male, uh, this,
this was a massive animal,
smaller than Tillikum the one
that's profiled in black face,
but I used to scratch
rate underneath that,
that sort of curvature and just peel
off the dead skin farm and he be just
shaking like, yeah man,
I'd be hitting it hard,
pulling out like a handful of dead
skin. Wow. Pretty Rhonda there. Wow,
that's crazy.
But how would they normally get that?
Would they rub it off on rocks?
So they wouldn't have,
they wouldn't accumulate that
dead skin. I mean, they're,
they're constantly swimming, constantly
moving. So the weight of the water,
the pressure that water would keep
that dorsal fin nice and erect. Right.
It's because they're all that surface
resting. There's nowhere for them to swim.
And I mean, there's not, the
pools are never deepened.
I think it doesn't properly
accommodate them. So,
and the people that work in these
facilities, how would, how do they,
how do they rationalize this?
How do they,
the first thing that needs to be stressed
as these are not bad people, people,
these are people that go
into these situations,
assuming that this is not only like a
socially acceptable thing, this isn't us,
this isn't just accept that
this is encouraged and, and,
and celebrate it. I mean,
seaworld was celebrated by the
masses, if you will, up until the law,
the release of blackfish prior to that,
they control the message.
So people see that and they're just
like, oh my God, that's amazing.
That's beautiful and amazing.
So when you're a 22 year old punk boy kid,
you're thinking, Hey, I want to, I want
to go get a gig doing that. That's,
that's the cat's ass job right there.
You get the Gig and now you're working
for someone while you're 22 years old,
you need a paycheck and your parents
had been pounding you down for your
lifetime that you could got to go up there
and you don't get a good job and work
as hard as you can and everything else.
So you're,
you're working for someone who owns this
facility and you believe you're doing
what's, what's your, what's in
the best interest of the animals.
You're there to care for the animals.
So you don't see the, the shitty part.
You don't think, wow, I'm doing
this. I never put the animal there,
the animals there. It's not just there,
it's, it's great that it's there.
People love that it's there.
This is a,
this is a job that people like
really want to get, get the Gig,
trying to do the right thing so it's not,
it's not bad people.
So then the rationalizing doesn't come
until you there for a really long time
when you have to really
start rationalizing some of
the decisions that are made.
Once you get closer to the upper echelon,
closer to the brass and you see
the decisions that are being made,
you're like Jesus,
but shouldn't we be doing this instead?
That's when you start questioning shit
and I guess it takes a really good person
at that point or the better part of the
people cause we never managed to keep
people at our facility there. I mean we
were going through a lot of good people.
That door was revolving in and out.
Do you think that as part of
that is like being disenchanted?
Part of it is like
realizing what you're doing.
Part of it is if you're
there for the right reasons,
you really give a shit about those animals
and it beats the shit out of you that
the decisions that are being made and
you're the muscle of that decision,
this isn't being made. You're the muscle
to execute it. You're just like, whoa,
wait a second.
We don't have to do that.
Like that we have to do
is making the decisions.
Well in my experience we don't have to
say names. Just like, well, I mean I was,
I worked for a facility
that was micromanaged by one
man who's been, who's been,
who's owned it now for 52 years.
Oh, see who owns it? He owns it.
He owns the slave plantation.
I can't say that I hit a launch a lot at
1.2 $5 million suit against me if I say
that.
So you're going to,
you said that I'm going to
get a lawsuit for saying that.
I think I should have
brought you a disclaimer.
Like I don't think I should
get sued for saying it's labor.
I think you should have to
prove that it's not. Well,
if you're a super intelligent animals
locked up in swimming pools, uh,
what are you doing?
If you've got the slavery,
if you've got the money to see
this process through the court,
then you can then impose that on him.
But if you don't have the money to defend
and you're like me getting attacked,
um, so the, so it's basically
one person's decisions and,
and then all the people that
really care about the animals are,
but he owns the joint. He has all the
cash he pays you, which gets you the beer,
the food. But he makes the decisions.
And does he make decisions?
Like does he have a
background in marine biology?
Like does he make educated decisions or
these financial decisions or like how to,
how to like the crueler aspects
of the job manifest itself.
But the problem with, I say
the problem, but with me it's,
I worked at a very unique
place that they're very few
facilities where it's like
one guy who owns it,
who's been doing this as long as you have.
It's hard to rationalize
his decision making.
I'm going to put a big asterisk next
to his name. Maybe other people,
I don't know.
But at the end of the day,
that's obviously there's a financial
aspect of the decision making. Um,
but
that story about that dolphin
open up his mouth and forced me.
That's the stuff of nightmares we
have to treat harbor seals like that.
I just think of what it must
be like to be that animal,
to be sucked out of your world at an
elderly age and stuffed into this tank
where you know you're never getting out.
We're like, there's no escape hatch.
You're not going to double o seven you
way out of this and fucking figure out
how to unjam me the door and make your
way down the dock and jumping in the
water and swim to freedom.
Especially in Niagara Falls. Man,
you're pretty landlocked
aside from some freshwater,
but dolphins are going to last long
there. Yeah. I try to rationalize it now.
It really was only until after I left.
When I quit my job, I come out in,
the first thing I did was I started
petitioning the Ontario government.
We need rules and regulations so that
these animals can live at least in an
environment that that is
more accommodating to them.
I wanted more greater animal
protection laws. This is, this was the,
this was the avenue I went because still
I was still disillusioned to the fact
that, hey, wait a second.
If you delve deeper to the day one of
them landing in the pool or being in that
in your possession,
there's a history there.
Go back there and see what's
what's happened there.
And suddenly the more I think about that,
that's when you start taking
the real shit kicking.
Cause you're like Holy Holy Shit.
Like this animal's been through a lot.
It's been through fricking lot
protecting it in captivity.
That's not really serving this animal a
lot of like you're not doing this animal
a big service like you need.
You need to abolish this all together.
So I would say the campaign has changed,
especially with blackfish coming up.
Cause people know now like this. It's
not, not only not fun, it's just not fun.
It's just disgustingly cruel. Like that's
a whole lifetime of shit for an animal.
That's again,
if you,
if you could relate to it instead
of separate yourself from it,
stop looking at it as an object.
Be that animal for a second.
Now try to be that animal for
a lot longer than a second.
You all of a sudden you start feeling
like pretty bad and wonder why we would
expect compassion from
aliens. You know? I mean,
think about what we can do to some of
the most obvious intelligent animals on
our planet that were different from,
well guess what?
The idea is something coming from another
fucking planet that has fingers and
eyes and a nose in front of its
face and looks just like you.
That's a fucking stretch.
More.
Most likely it's going to be just as
bizarre to you as an Orca is to you.
And so if you look at
the way we treat orchids,
why the fuck would we ever
expect anybody to be nice to us?
I used to exercise the analogy of um,
of aliens with the younger trainers
all the time. I'd say, look,
we're aliens to these animals.
You need to make this animal's
environment as comfortable as possible.
Bearing in mind always we are
aliens. Just, you know what I mean?
That's part of relating to the animals,
which is they're thinking like that.
You're just like, wait a second.
Like I got it to start being nicer.
Because if an alien comes down, I
don't want that. I don't want to be,
it's a stupid thing to say like it's one
of those who your talking about aliens
gun people like automatically go goofy
with it. But the reality is it's actually,
it's the right analogy because we really
are aliens in their world and we're
obviously supposedly intelligent.
We're obviously intelligent enough
to figure out how to get them when
intelligent enough to how to figure out
how to train them, put them in tents.
We can put them in tanks rather have
all these people come to see him.
We're obviously intelligent,
have to film them theirs.
They can tell there's a lot of shit
going on that they don't do but they've
gotta be like, God you guys are dicks.
Like why are you holding onto me?
Like we don't hold onto it. We don't,
we don't, we don't, we don't do that.
I think we killed things
but we don't hold onto them.
I think that's when the frustration
level start boiling for these animals.
Cause when they're first there, when they
first arrived, he was a green animal.
If there,
I mean the bottom line is,
it depends if they're a good
candidate for captivity,
but they learned real fast that,
okay, that's the hand that feeds me.
Like I wanna I wanna I want to develop
this relationship, if you will,
which is the relationship of like
abiding by this person's rules, right?
Then again,
goodwill,
the animals and the other ones that
are just like the same for me. There,
they're there, they're cutting out and
there's nothing you can do. I mean,
you pull blood from them, you check that
blood. There's nothing wrong with them.
This animal's not sick. Why isn't
it eating? And then days later,
why is this animal debt did
not want to be in captivity.
They just starved themselves to death.
I've seen it so many times, wow.
The will to live loss.
And you're like,
that was always the most
frustrating thing for me.
And you're gonna make me fucking cry.
Every time I ever watched
an animal lose its will.
That was the most that that destroyed me,
that destroyed me. It's like, it's over.
The will is gone. You're not going
to find a cause of death here.
They just stopped eating style.
How does the the main guy deal with all
this? How does the guy owns these joints?
Let's hypothetically,
okay,
let's not even talk about
any one person in particular,
but there's a bunch of these things
out there. There's the, there's these,
these seaworld type places all over
the world, right? Like I said, Marina,
animal places,
whatever you want to call them.
The most difficult thing you
can try to do is rationalize.
Especially in in my particular experience
is the decision making that's going on
at there. You just can't. Anything that
you think is a good idea is a bad one.
Do you come and direct communication
with the people that own the place?
I did eventually.
Of course I was there 12 years,
so I mean I was by all
means up there and the,
have you ever been there when
these ideas are expressed?
Have you ever been in front of like any
people that own these places and say,
hey, you know what we're doing is
really fucked up. I don't have a job
no more because it was the slamming of
the fist that was going on when these
decisions were being made.
That ultimately led to me being
like the slamming of the fist.
What do you mean that decision's
being made? You got to do this. Okay,
so this is what we do. This is how we
train them. Get Out of my office. Say No,
lose your job.
I was that.
I was the asshole who was going to get
fired real soon. It's a children's movie.
It's like a movie. Yeah. It's
like, you know what I mean?
It's like some Whoville type
shit where you know you, you,
you see this evil thing being perpetrated
by someone who's just in it for money
and not thinking about the
humanity of the whole thing.
It's funny you mentioned that we,
we had a Christmas show we were
putting together and these,
there's these brothers that do these
animated shorts and Canada, you know,
they're, they're pretty
well known. Anyways,
they had produced this video and
they gave it to us and you know,
the colleagues were like,
yeah,
this should be great to show it during
the Christmas show. Okay. Put it in.
The cartoon was of this old man who went
and stole a wild baby walrus from its
mother and you don't want to know exactly
how those that gets done. Of course,
the, the cartoons, you know, less graphic,
but then he grabs a
polar bear and his ideas,
he's going to have these two
things dual and, and fight it out.
Then basically the Mont, the mother
Walrus comes back and the, and the mother,
a polar bear and they, you
know, they get the bad guy,
but we showed that video
during a Christmas show. I'm
watching this going, shit.
That reminds me of someone.
Hypothetically, hypothetically.
It's, it's very, it's very sad that
we don't have laws stopping this.
I think that's what this fights a boat.
I mean that's what, that's the stink.
I started along a while back. I think
there's something about the zoo too.
I wrote a piece a long time ago about
the zoo, about it being animal prison.
I eat a pot cooking and went to the
zoo once. Eddie Bravo, my friend Eddie,
he ate five grams of mushrooms allegedly
and went to the zoo once and he said it
was the most depressing thing he's ever
seen his life. He said it was so sad,
like the reality of what the zoo is just
was in escapable, the sadness of it all.
He had to get out of there and I felt
like that after I eat a pot cookies,
I eat a pod cookie and I went
to the zoo and I sat there. I,
there's a bench across from the chimpanzee
and closure at the La Zoo and I sat
for like a half hour,
40 minutes just staring at this one
chimp just trying to think about what his
life is like, what is where, where the,
the the wonder of the natural,
the natural world living in the jungle,
living off the land,
doing what they've done for fucking
a million years or whatever.
The chimpanzees have been around that
the freedom and laughter and the,
they would want around fucking each
other and grabbing bananas and Shit.
I mean they live like ultimately in
almost an Adam and eve type paradise.
It's utopia man. It is with chimpanzees.
It's for Utopia. I mean, yeah,
there's dangerous. Sure. This jaguars,
they can suddenly start protecting animals
from other animals. But not only that,
we have that same problem.
There's a fucking mountain line.
They just photographed the Hollywood hills
this week. Jesus Christ.
It's, that's a call. Call it,
they caught it at one point in
time. Yeah, we're cute. We caught,
we catch fucking giant monsters
and we release them. We were like,
be free monster. We're in your
neighborhood and we respect that.
You have to wonder like it took,
it took your buddy like five grams or
shrooms and you had one of your pot cakes
to,
to be able to exercise that perspective
of sort of like liberating yourself from
all the bullshit, like the
flashing lights, the neon
disasters, everything else.
And I think that's why people rationalize,
cause they're always a nun
data with everything so much
that they can't just for
a second sit down and stare at that
animal's eyes just for a second.
And if it scares you,
don't turn away because the
first thing people that are just,
first thing I'll do is I
just, I just exercise too much
attention. Then it's also,
there's, there's the issue of it being
there already and when it's their running,
it's sanctioned and you see adults
walking back and forth pushing strollers,
it seems like it's okay.
And I look,
I'm a hypocrite because I take my
kids to the zoo, they love the zoo.
Then they're young and they,
they enjoy looking at animals and it's
fascinating to be there live and see a
giraffe like whoa. And to feed the
Giraffe, I get it. You know, I get it,
but it's, it's probably better
if we didn't have it. It's,
it seems like a fucked up thing. And this
is coming from a deer hunter. You know,
I'd like hunting animals.
I like eating animals.
I've been a mediator my whole life.
But I don't think you should lock them up.
I think they should be free. I
think the wild animals, you know,
there they are.
There's some,
there's something magical and special
about seeing something in the wild,
something that's moving
around living its life.
There's something inherently sad about
seeing something we took from the wild
and then made it live in a city.
It doesn't replicate that experience
in any capacity. What's it now?
Is it not replicated?
Like we don't give a fuck.
We're just saying we don't care what we,
I know what you like, but getting there.
I want to say we used to
not give a fuck though.
Do you think people were more aware now?
I don't doubt that for a second.
If there's a physical huge paradigm shift,
like people are not interested in
seeing that no more with everything.
I think a lot of things,
I think with life itself,
I think what we're experiencing now
because of the Internet is a reality that
never existed before. A way of
communicating that we're never existing,
that it never existed before. And I
think the amount that it's changing us,
it's happening so rapidly and it's
so deep that we have a hard time
understanding what's really going on.
I think we're in the middle of a
hurricane of information and it's changing
every single aspect. It's changing
things for the good and for the bad.
It's changing things in weird ways.
It's uh,
there's a lot of confirmation
bias because of it.
A lot of people are grouping up on online
find likeminded morons who believe the
earth is hollow and that there's fucking
a certain group of people that live in
the middle of it.
You could find a message board with those
people will believe you and they'll,
they'll go with you.
There's just this weird aspects to this,
but that it's select the
inevitable aberrations and
this fucking rolling tsunami
of of ones and Zeros and information
that's coming our way. I think on a whole,
the larger like demographic of people,
you know, not, not the,
not the tiny pockets,
but there's probably some
relativity between the tiny
pockets and the masses are
pretty sick of it. Like
you know, I don't know.
Like I think they think
about it for the most part.
That's what I was going to say is like,
because it's there because
the zoos are already there.
You don't think about it cause
sea world's already there.
You don't think about it. It's their
adults are running it. See, hey, hi.
How are you?
I'm assuming there's rules.
You assume there's rules and
there's regulations and like,
oh they must be doing
something right because look,
it's being celebrated like Holy Shit
like that. That looks kind of small,
but they must know something we don't.
So it must be perfectly calm down
to sea world guy, the director,
he's so friendly.
He's waving at everybody.
He wouldn't be mean to the
dolphins to get him to jump.
While you're not mean to the dolphin
though, this is the difficult,
like this is the thing. When
you're, when you're there,
you don't think you're being mean.
You're being mean by plucking a moat.
That's really fucking mean.
But asking them to do the jump
and training them to do the jump.
You don't exercise that perspective
that you're being mean. So I,
I worked with a lot of the
seaworld breasts that are
in black fish and you know,
it isn't until after you see what the,
what they're saying in court,
some of the things they're doing
you just like, that guy was awesome.
He was a nice guy, man.
Like that guy's a dick.
What kind of things in
Cordy talking about well,
lies of course lies
allegedly lies or let's say,
let's pretend these people
that aren't even real people,
there are two tranches that are on trial.
Um,
what are they guilty of and what are they
claiming? Well, there's your Angeles.
I mean,
even people at the end of the day,
they're trying to keep
their business very viable,
keep the rules out the trenches,
have an aunt business they run,
they train aunts and they get
these ants to do flips. Well,
they pay people very
little money to train them.
They pay people very little money.
They convinced those people who are
legitimately good and animal caring.
You know,
people that care for animals that are,
they're going to convince them that
what they're doing, it's good. Pay Them.
Very little put, you know, there's
a system of oppression. There were,
like I said before, this, that hammer,
that fist comes down and you're,
now you're the muscle. Like the idea
is here, you don't like the idea,
but you're the muscle to execute it or
these profitable businesses. Oh Shit.
I thought if you knew what I was up
against in Niagara Falls and I can fall,
it's not a big place.
If you knew what I was up
against in Niagara Falls to
be like, is it profitable?
Like is it, did they yield
a lot of influence? Um,
at every level of government and
everything else? Yeah, maybe. What did,
what did you do that you got
in trouble for? What happened?
So I quit my job and I didn't get
in trouble for that. Why'd you quit?
Couldn't do it. You couldn't do it
anymore. You just hit a breaking point.
I hit a breaking point long before I quit.
And so the quitting was like a mist.
What was like the craziness after you
go beyond that threshold of a breaking
point. So yeah, I got out. So before
you quit you are making stink,
stink big stinks.
What were you doing?
I was trying to keep from keep
what was going on from happen,
from continuing.
I was trying to stop,
I was trying to fix an
otherwise really big problem,
like a glaringly evident that
problem that everyone is seeing.
Like we got a big problem here.
Who's going to,
who's going to fight to change this?
You start looking around and
yeah, that's not happening. This
avenue is not exercising it.
This one pretends to be ready
to exercise something, but
yeah.
So then you got it.
You just say it's very difficult for you
to communicate this because of the fact
that you have a lawsuit going on. So
you're dancing around stuff a little bit.
I got a dance a little bit. Yeah.
When? Once the trailer? Yeah. Yeah.
Let's watch a trailer.
Okay. Hold on one sec.
Okay.
What does the trailer for explaining
blackfish official trailer
shit
the fuck out. When you look into their
eyes, he knows somebody gets home.
An animal that possesses great
spiritual power not to be metal. Yes.
Bye County sheriff's office.
We need to reform for the world.
Yeah,
a whale
telecom.
How is the one that went after her
and dawn is the senior trainer
here at Shampoos Stadium.
She captured what it means
to be a sea world trainer.
That it made me realize what happened to
her. Really could've happened to anyone.
I've been expecting somebody
to be killed by telecom.
We weren't told much about
it other than it was trainer.
It didn't just happen. It's
not a thing. Killer adventure.
You have to go back to understand this
speed.
Boats and heard of the man and make
could just pick out the young ones.
This was the worst thing.
Oh.
When Tillikum arrived at seaworld,
he was twice as large as the next
animal meat store. These whales,
you don't want to call a module which
was 20 feet across and 30 feet deep and
the lights were all term.
No,
probably led to what I
think is a psychosis.
Oh Wales captivity, all psychologically
traumatized. It's not just telecom.
If you were in a bathtub for 25 years,
don't you think you'd
get a little psychotic?
Dawn would tell you that it was
her mistake they blamed for,
that's just a bold face lies. I was
just instructed to get rid of it. Dang
street has a vested interest in spinning
things that sells a lot of sham dolls.
It sells a lot of tickets.
Set the gate.
There was no record of the
Norco doing any harm. Wow.
You should just watch that.
They should play that for the
judge and the judge who go, stop.
This fucking case is over. This thing's
not going to cart. It's a slap suit.
It's a strategic lawsuit against public
participation. He wants me broke.
He wants me to not be able to get
through this judicial process,
which right off the hop
is really expensive,
but when you see something
like black fish come out,
that's got to support your
cause tremendously. Uh,
I like to think I'm an
a can't lose situation.
Like this thing has been building the
craziest momentum off the hop. It was,
I mean, that's a scary endeavor.
Doing what we did, being where we are.
That's scary shit. What does that mean?
Doing what we did? What did you do?
A newspaper called? They found
out the Walrus guy quit his job.
They want to know why you were
the Walrus trainer, the Walrus,
the walrus trainer among other things,
among other things.
They want to know why you pick up that
phone and you're amidst the scariest,
the scarier parts of depression
and you're not touching that.
You're not touching that. I got,
I got things to process like, um,
I'm not touching that.
And then a situation,
a scenario unfolds where suddenly you
realize you have to touch that someone has
to,
and so you pick up the phone.
Okay.
And then 14 other people for that matter,
wind up picking up the phone.
As you know, these stories start
to, as this investigation continues,
okay.
The decision I made different than
than other people, for instance,
and I can understand and appreciate
why they had their reasons I do.
Mine is to not use your face and image.
I said,
go ahead. It's, it's filled
Merce, it's filled. Immerse.
Who's talking to this newspaper right
now? Go ahead. Something has to be done.
Newspaper prints. Front
page, shit gets crazy.
It doesn't just last for a day or two. And
what was the allegations? What did you,
what did you accuse him of or what was
the, what was the big revelation? Well,
okay.
The facility that I worked at,
animals were suffering.
Okay.
Simple as that. Simple as
suffering. Just basic reality.
The reality of those facilities.
Every animal suffers in those places.
They suffer from a lack of freedom.
Yes. Right? Yes. This one, there's an,
this is an exceptional case.
We had serious short staffing
issues over the years. I mean,
I watched that department
go like this went from,
they don't experience staff to like
what's going on here? Like what do we,
what are we down to? And then there
was like a mechanical breakdown in a,
the water disinfection units, a
big one. Oh, the water was nasty.
Oh,
and instead of dumping the water,
instead of addressing the issue
over the course of the off season,
I remembered week closed.
You know,
we're only a in operation for
like five months out of the year.
And then thereafter we're close to the
public because it's so cold because it's
so cold, so cold. So then,
so amidst that, you know,
the water disinfection unit breaks in,
let's say August or September.
We closed in like October. Well now
we're in November, December, January.
It's steeped. We're opening
in May. This is bad.
And the resolve, just a
little history. As far as the,
the water disinfection unit goes, we're
talking about an ozone machine. Ozone,
the way it works, it works in
conjunction with chlorine. It, it,
it allows for you to use less chlorine
to disinfect the water. Ozones out. Well,
how are you gonna how are you going
to treat the water in a purse in a,
in a less than rational
person thinking person's mind?
You may think it's a good idea to put
a shit ton of chlorine in and a lot and
repeatedly in really scary doses when
employees aren't around overnight.
For instance.
And this went on and this continued to
go on and that's when I couldn't do it no
more.
I can't do this.
So you knew that these
animals are basically being
poisoned by all the chlorine,
that there was something terrible,
was serious damage done. Fuck,
lots of serious damage done.
Is there a movement at all to,
to outlaw these things now
after something like blackfish?
So I petitioned the Ontario government to
enact or to create stronger
animal protection laws,
which they just announced to throw in
five and a half million dollars a year
instead of half a million dollars to
the Eos PCA to, to correct this issue.
The OSP, the, the, uh, agency that, well,
I don't have a lot of good
things to say about them.
I think we'll leave it at that for now.
But I hate that there's
an animal protection.
I know at the thing and that they
handle orcas and dolphins. Well, they,
they don't though. They should.
I mean, they shouldn't. It
should be like we should,
it should be the department of
humanity. You know, they should,
people should be able to get together,
take a look at one of those things,
get close to them and go,
okay, what are we doing here?
This is where my efforts wet
from animal protection and uh,
you know, regulations and
standards of care to abolishment.
It's got to go right in
Canada. You can't capture, uh,
any whales in your own water. Can't do it,
can't get a permit, is not gonna exist.
You can buy from Russia, you could buy
from Japan. Any of these drive, uh, hunts,
uh, the, you know, similar to the
orchids that are shipped to, to Russia.
They w you can catch him in a wild,
bring them in to ship them down.
I'm trying to have that outlawed.
Like,
you should not be able to
do that in Canada no more.
And I'm working my ass off,
made a big stink and
we're still only this far.
They're this far being around
the world and like it just,
anytime pub people listening you're like
not very far. Well, it doesn't take,
it doesn't take long for a government.
Someone else to step in and say,
what are we talking about? Oh, we've got
to talk about jobs, and then you're gone.
You know,
you're in the back seat of the bus again,
way at the back and you're like, okay,
I've got to start claw my way back up.
How am I going to get, make a
stink again? And then southern,
like blackfish comes out.
I saw this dude when telecom was as his
name telecom till when Tillikum killed
that lady. I'm the trainer that I
saw this guy freaking out about it.
Like this disgusting beast. They
should kill this thing. It was,
it was fascinating. He was a,
I don't know where he was from.
It was from another country,
but he was talking to his friend about
it and it was interesting to watch that
site. Some, some people's
perspectives are so off like this.
This is like some Parana
in there that's eating.
People like that thing is looking at
fish's eyes like a Paranas eyes. You know,
he buys, I'll be looking at a Budweiser
bottle. They're fucking idiots.
Everyone in blackfish said the same thing.
They're like telecom was the nicest
Orca ever. I knew candy big male.
I knew Ike Tillikum son.
We had till it comes soon until,
see where we'll actually successfully sued
marine land to have him remove and uh,
we can, how do they do that? They know
what they know. How do they do that?
How do they separate
them from their children?
Ike Ike was an amazingly beautiful animal.
Good natured.
He was going to kill someone. He
was going to kill someone. Wow. No.
Now is there like regulation on
how small the the tanks can be?
If we got nothing and
Ken, if you, Hey, listen,
if you're ever hard up, if let's say
tomorrow, you're like, shit, I need it.
I need a really high paying gig.
Just come to Ontario, dig a hole.
I know a couple of guys with the bacco.
Well dig a hole.
We'll fill it with whatever you want. I
got the contacts in Russia, you'll have,
you'll call them, you'll buy a couple of
dolphins will throw him in there. Boom,
you're money's made and you don't
have to worry about anything.
No regulatory bodies. There's
no import laws. There is
nothing. It's, it's the wild,
wild west is there. Like
that's incredible. Is there,
are there new ones that are
being made now? Like they're,
they're making like a
new, no often world. Well,
in Toronto they actually just
opened the Ripley's aquarium.
They have sharks, they've got other
sharks. I don't give a fuck about sharp.
They've got animals.
But you have to sort of wonder like
what's the environmental impact is of
actually getting those shark. He started
thinking there. You're like, well, that,
that, that seems pretty
shitty. Yeah. Well, no doubt.
We're fucking the ocean up.
There's no doubt about that. And I,
I'm with you on that and I'm, you know,
I'm even with you on the idea of like,
I don't think,
I don't really have a problem with
sharks at an aquarium. I know,
I see them swimming around, they
get fed. I think they're stupid.
They're dumb killing machines
and it doesn't really bother me.
My problem is with
things that are thinking,
but that exact perspective that
you're exercising right now,
we may very well find out otherwise
in 50 years be like, Holy Shit,
look what we're doing. The
sharks, like they're mad geniuses,
we must find something. Who
knows, right? Yeah, maybe.
But it doesn't seem like
there's any natural advantage
to them being intelligent.
They're basically just swing
their steam machines. Yeah,
they're all they're doing,
I mean obviously I'm joking around,
I don't think we should
make sharks extinct.
And I do think that the impact that
we're having on all marine life is pretty
profound. It very disturbing
and not that disgust. I mean,
occasionally you'll see an article online
about the garbage patch in the Pacific
and then the several other patches
that they found all over the country,
all over the world,
rather,
where there's these whirlpools generate
these areas where there's just a massive
con con condensed garbage and
plastic and gyres. They're called
Texas sized. Yeah. But you know
what happens is filled with shit.
Anyone decides to start
reading up on that.
And then what happens is the right wing
media sort of comes in and it's just
like, no, no, no. I've heard these
guys are all activists. Exactly.
I've heard that and I've actually had
conversations online with people about
that with like, look, it's not
that big a deal. It's not that big.
It's you've got to realize the
perspective of the oceans and norm.
It's the size of Texas man.
This is an area the size of Texas has
little pieces of plastic floating around
in silence. An expert, right,
and it's like goop apparently.
It's like a lot of the plastic is sort
of dissolves this weird consistency and
animals wind up eating it,
opening up these animals and seeing
plastic figurines like army figurines in
them. Like that's pretty crazy.
Albatrosses a lot of their mother,
the mother Albatross doesn't know the
plastic is and thinks it's some kind of
food, so she feeds it to the babies
and there was this one island that is a
uninhabited by people,
but it's a major island
for these albatrosses and
this photographer went over
there and took all these photographs
of albatrosses can hear that.
Obviously all these photographs of
albatrosses with plastic inside of their
bodies. Yeah, I saw that in
the nests. Like so fucked.
So weird.
But if you're not there and you're the
person that sees this and if you don't
look away immediately as it scares you
or caused us concern that how you're
going to know you just let it go.
You don't care.
Well it's also the same thing as the
zoo. It's key. It's always been there.
You know, there's always been garbage
in the ocean, whatever, whatever.
It's not my responsibility to fix this.
Someone out there is a real grownup.
Someone out there is older than me and
wiser and has the role of the head of the
Department of fucking keeping fish alive
and he's going to keep it together.
That's the perspective.
That's exercise.
The second anyone even thinks
about going to these places. Oh,
we're going to that place where the people
who know what they're doing or doing
that thing that we all love and that is
awesome. So let them do their job fill.
The guys are trying to keep the,
wasn't for them.
No one would even give
a fuck about orchids.
The Japanese would be killing them
and making sandwiches with dolphins.
They got away with that for a long time.
They controlled the message.
Now all of a sudden with you,
like you say the binary digits,
the information that you know,
the information superhighway,
we're all learning.
Yeah. We're all learning. So what happened
with you? So you get out of there, you,
you, you do this, you do this story. You
tell everybody what the fuck's going on.
When is the lawsuit happened
and what is the lawsuit?
The lawsuit doesn't happen for
a bit. The lawsuit first. The,
the first thing they do is they make
it very difficult for they allegedly,
I mean it's an,
it's an obligation,
but they allegedly make things very
difficult for my girlfriend who's been
working there for 12 years as well.
She's actually Kiska the loan
Orkos head trainer. Okay.
And things start becoming really difficult
for her. She still worked there? No,
in the off season, they, they fired
her fast. They had to, they had to, uh,
it was costing them a lot of money for
information to continue to be leaked.
I assume that they probably
thought it was coming from her,
but there were a lot of people talking
at this time because the story wasn't
just one story that come out.
When I had spoken to the media,
this thing went on for like eight months
a year.
They're still talking about,
there's still stories coming out of
this thing, uh, since the lawsuits, uh,
former employees and certainly
current deployed or not talking,
but so first thing they did was made
things exceptionally difficult for her and
then they fired her
and then they sued her.
Then they waited awhile or they sued
her for defamation because there was a
video that was provided to,
um,
the newspaper and in the video there's a,
the orcas tail is bleeding,
it's bleeding.
And in the news article,
she as a former employee who
had just been fired, said,
I'm concerned for the killer
whale because she's bleeding.
And so they're suing her for defamation.
Again, it's called a slap suit.
They're not a 10th.
Sue You for saying that you're
concerned when you're a trainer.
They could sue me for anything.
It doesn't matter. It doesn't.
The lawsuit is there. Slap suits.
Again, they have, they're there.
They don't have any real,
like there's nothing tangible there and
they could write a fiction story about
you. You got to get a lawyer retain
one that's five k off the hop.
If you're lucky, then you got to
submit a statement of defense.
That's another couple of thousand dollars.
Kickstarter. I got an Indiegogo. Well,
I'm on my fourth Indiegogo, uh,
fundraising campaign right now. Yeah.
How do,
I know this is not an elaborate scheme
between you and the owner of that place
to just make Indiegogo money.
Can you look up the video that you
guys are pretending that you're a war?
Maybe let's, can you just,
just sucking saps into pain,
Indiegogo money.
Just go on Youtube and put up like marine
land animals suffering and we'll go to
the video. You could, you can see, listen,
I'm just fucking around and I know,
I don't know.
It might be worth to watch anyways.
I don't know that you've seen it.
I mean you don't want to see blackfish.
Honestly, I don't want to see
anymore. It is pretty brutal.
It's all the very depressed.
Don't pull up any of that shit.
I don't want to see it.
I know what's going on and I think
now the real conversation isn't like
repeating the same images and watching
the same videos or we don't need to go
there. I think what we need to do now is
figure out how we're going to stop these
things from being legal because this
is what I'm doing in Ontario at least.
Right? Yeah. I think it needs to be done.
I think the people that own these places,
I know that they've made a living doing
this for a long time and I believe some
of them probably do have a
real love for these animals,
but people didn't need to stop. Everyone
need to stop. The trainers need to stop.
They need to stop. It's, it's dark.
It's just too fucked up. You're, you're,
you're in slaving intelligent animals.
It's tough to get to the trainers.
They're young people who's going,
who are going to get a kick
ass gig. That's the Gig. I
mean, again, paradigm shift.
Up until a year ago, this was the
case. Now, you know, with the,
with the Toronto Star investigation
in the marine land with blackfish,
people are now just like, Whoa, like what
that commercial said? It was awesome.
Remember that jingle like that was
awesome. Why is this job shitty?
Why are these animals being tortured?
Yeah. Now they know, but again, the,
the industry control the
information for so long.
So Russia is still ganking them out of
the water. We don't do that anymore. Uh,
the states don't,
you need a to import from anywhere.
And because what happens is to,
to apply for a permit,
there's a period of like public,
a opinion or whatever.
They sort of write in and basically these
agencies get the shit kicked out on.
Someone really needs to make a movie
where a human gets kidnapped and taken to
an alien fucking human world.
That will be a fascinating movie.
When he got taken to some alien version
of seaworld and humans are doing fucking
cartwheels and shit, I'd be
the right time. It's a leap.
Like that could totally be like some
crazy avatar type movie where they would
have meetings to decide when human is
allowed to be transferred to another
facility,
removed them from their families,
or are you going to have an incessant
scene? Because that's what goes on.
A lot of these facilities really with
the trainers, not with the trainer stone.
What are you saying? The
animals. The animals.
Of course there's not enough natural
selection. There's not enough out there.
You've got to get the killer whales.
It's difficult to bring them in,
so they just want to fuck in their
daughters and stuff. They don't want to,
but if you get them at the right time
and they're frustrated enough, I imagine,
I can't rationalize why medically candy
would do that to the Osha, but that,
that conceivably to happen so
dark. That's so dark. Yeah,
that was a tough one. Oh, it's so dark.
It's just fucking torture all around.
It's so crazy that no one recognizes
that and it's because they'd been
extracting money from this.
This being sanctioned for a long time.
It's generated a tremendous amount of
money and they've gotten addicted to that
money and they can't find
another way to make money.
They can't open up a barbecue shop.
They can't fucking sell hats.
I want to sell cowboy boots.
Fuck this dolphin training.
Know everybody keeps doing the same
thing over and over again because it's
always been a viable job. They reinvested
the money in government lobbying.
They reinvest that money in controlling
the message through the media.
They reinvested the money, you know,
making the right friends. And if you saw,
if you knew, especially in the small
community of Niagara Falls in Ontario,
what the angles and the things that are
happening, it's like, are you kidding me?
Like I assumed I was
up against some tough,
I knew it was gonna be difficult to try
to get these laws and it was not gonna
be easy. I mean, who? Who passes
laws, who lobbied to pass laws?
These laws that are coming out
are jokes, man. They're jokes.
They don't address what was,
what was the big stink a year ago when
these stories come out? Like what? Wow,
there's,
oh,
the laws that basically
the Ontario government just
celebrated the announcement
because again,
this was a big stink about when we had
come out and we petitioned the Ontario
government, um, they made a
law or I'd rather, they said,
we're going to create standards
of care for marine mammals.
We're going to enhance our
animal protection. It sounds
good. They announced all,
the only thing they announced thus
far is another announcement of, uh,
standards of care to come,
which are going to be,
which are going to be weighed
against the impact of communities.
So suddenly taking care of a dolphin has
something to do with whether or not Joe
Schmo down the street gets a job
from the facility around the corner.
There's a relate, there's,
that's relative somehow bullshit.
But that's apparently coming.
And again,
we built in a long time for
these fricking, you know,
it's always announcements
of announcements.
Then they announced an
influx of cash to the OSP,
5 million extra dollars a
year to protect animals.
Always Pca, Bung this thing up. The owner,
allegedly the owner of marine land bought
the land that the Osp ca operates out
of.
And I recall in my history seeing quite
frequently the LSPC agents coming in and
we're talking like what
does that sound stand for?
Ontario Society of prevention
of cruelty to animals. Okay,
so if there's animal cruelty happening,
you would assume that these are the
people that are going to come in and say,
Hey, stop that now and you
know, write a fine or something.
But well when their office is in the
building on the land that was donated by
the owner of the park,
that becomes a bit of a conflict of
interest cause I don't know that that that
individual is being paid 10 bones and
hour to drive around from facility to
facility. If that job should have come
a is going to turn around and be like,
hey man,
like we're shutting you down because
that chlorine that's causing a animal's
eyes to bleed, uh, skin to flake off
all sorts, everything else that's cruel.
There's just, it's very thin.
The rules are not there.
The other thing about the Ontario be seen,
the offices are on seaworld
properties that we were saying. No,
I'm not saying that. I'm saying in my
case or hypothetically, the owner of mine,
not hypothetically matter of factly,
the owner of my,
the facility that I worked at bought
the land and donated it to the Osp ca of
which there, uh, office, uh, uh,
of which they operate out of.
That's hilarious. It doesn't stop.
It doesn't end there man. It
doesn't, where's it end? Well,
it ends with me fighting
lawsuits. Right, right, right.
When you say it doesn't end there,
like what else? What other ways?
That's hilarious. The fat. I mean,
that's like heroin dealers donating
money to the cops. Like, here,
we're going to buy your fucking police
station. Let us keep dealing heroin,
please. So what happened with me? So
basically the, the newspaper outlet,
the media outlet that took our
story and ran with it really,
really beat the shit and
exposed a lot of things. Okay.
Marine land hires this gentleman
by the name of John Beatty.
He's the former McGinty senior
adviser. Mcginty was the, uh,
was the prime minister or rather
the premier of Ontario, this guy,
the owner Marineland high or
rather rather marine land.
The corporation hires John Beatty,
former advisor to the liberal government.
A gentleman by the name of uh, Shit,
I'm drawing a blank, but anyways,
uh, hires this senior, uh, you know what
I'm talking about if I'm consulting,
whatever. So this guy comes
out with a shit ton of spins,
videos and everything else,
and then he starts shaking the hands
of all the friends and the liberal
government. So when the announcement of
these new rules come out, you're like,
of course nothing's coming out.
You just hired the
premier's ex chief advisor.
He knows all the fricking people.
What are you talking about?
Then you start looking at it at the local
level of all the government, while the,
the, the, the Ministry of Environment.
The minister is a friend
of the owners as well.
There's great deal of history
everywhere, here, everywhere.
So everything one by one can remember a
lot of agencies went in there to it to
investigate.
They took a really long time sort of
releasing their findings and everything
sort of went by the wayside.
Slowly but surely there's there throw
a lawsuits around like like a candy at
Halloween, but everything else is
just sort of, because you know,
the stink sort of mellowed out didn't it?
You know,
you make a stink now in a year.
Well a lot of things are in the news
now that are different for that matter.
Mcginty drop like that stepped down.
So I lost that here I had to uh,
this premiere that was going to,
yeah,
we're going to do something real sad about
this. Then he bails out. I'm like, okay,
what happen to those laws we were
working on? Because you know, I was,
I was going traveling back
and forth to Queen's Park.
I was speaking with the Minister
of community safety. You know,
she's the one responsible for the OSP.
Ca Acts.
She's going to change things
and I'm talking to her,
we're going to change things and I
think we are, I really believe this.
I can't believe I'm making a change and
in the world here I get sued for doing
that. I'm getting sued now
I'm in a lawsuit. Holy Shit.
Well she can't talk to me.
Oh, that, that's in the courts
now. Can't talk no more.
And then everything's falling by
the wayside. I'm like, Holy Shit.
Like turns out like defending animals
is a really scary thing to do.
Well,
it's not
really just defending animals.
What you're doing is you're
going up against a machine,
you're going up against a machine that
generates money and as a bunch of people
that are profiting from it. Right.
So what's happening? Big machine big.
And at the end of the day it's all
about it comes down to the monies.
It comes down to the monies and
these police facilities generate.
Now when your situation
start and when was black?
Black fist was only released like a
month ago or two, right? Uh, on CNN,
like a month and change ago. Yeah.
And when did your scenario fired?
When it all caught up pass.
August 15th of last year was the day
that our story come out. And again,
it wasn't just me.
We were like eight or nine people at that
point that it kept building cause more
stories would come out like,
and then more people would come out until
the lawsuit started dropping. Right.
That's when people are like,
what? And you, you don't
plan on suing them back. Oh,
I'm suing them back. What
are you suing them back for?
Well, defamation, number one,
they really,
well they released a video of me calling
me an animal liberation army leading
like they turned around and made
me eat meat. I used to eat meat.
I used to exclusively, I was a meat
and potato guy pounded all day.
Now I'm having a real tough time. Like
I'll, I'll eat meat, but when I do,
I feel guilt so it makes it
less appetizing. I can't get
off cheese. I'm off milk,
you know, eating a hell of a lot
healthier, exercising more, you know,
different things happening and
you try to clear your mind.
When I processing this,
I have a friend who's a vegetarian, he
eats eggs because eggs come from chickens.
They just lay them.
Then they're not,
we have this idea that eggs
going to become a chick.
They're not the chickens
lay eggs every day. Um,
and he'll eat meat if somebody
he know killed it if it's hunted,
but he won't, he won't buy any factory
bought me and you want, he says,
I don't want to participate in that
system. He's like, you don't have to,
you can get organic eggs.
There's nothing wrong with those eggs
and you can get your protein from that.
He just won't, he won't participate
in the cheeseburger system.
He won't participate in the
factory farming system. And it's,
it's basically the broad
spectrum of human behavior,
the fact that we can be almost saintly
and beautiful and people can pick people
up off the side of the road and,
and help them along their way.
And then on the other hand,
we could be the type of
person that stuff's a thousand
chickens and do a fucking
10 foot square room and has them
stacked on top of each other,
shitting on each other's heads and then
just pull them out and cut their heads
off. And you know they can't walk because
we've engineered them to have these
gigantic fucking breasts within
a, you know, a year of being born.
I don't think a lot of people know
that it's when you turn your wins,
when you open your eyes to that,
if you're,
if again it comes back to there's the
truth, how much you want to delve into it.
As soon as it gets scary,
people tuck tail and run.
But it's just we've got to figure out
what the fuck makes the difference in the
spectrum.
What makes a person that goes out of
their way not to step on a bug and what
makes a person who has zero problem with
stuff and a thousand chickens into a
fucking closet?
Like what?
What's the difference between those two
individuals and how do you bridge that
gap?
How do you,
how do you make it so that everybody
who's walking around like number one,
the number one thing that they're
thinking of is don't, don't be cruel.
Don't be evil and nasty.
Don't,
don't do something that would ultimately
be looked on in Har if it was made
public. That's essentially what
a lot of factory farming is.
It depends what perspective you're
exercising and you're exercising.
The perspective of person whose
objective is to make a lot of money.
I know the objective of a,
a person whose objective is to
understand where their food comes from.
Well then most people are not, they're
not going to eat factory farmed meats.
No question. Yeah. Most people have zero
idea how dark the whole situation is.
The more I know, the less I, I went
to a, um, uh, butchering house,
a slaughterhouse I guess, uh, once
for a fear factor stunt and dude,
when, I mean I'm not a like
a fucking woo kind of guy.
I think a lot of woo woo
stuff is bullshit. But I felt
that that place felt sad.
You can feel it felt sad,
like the air felt sad.
Like it was a big pocket of death.
My buddy worked for the Canadian Food
Inspection Agency and he had to go in
there. He's a vegetarian.
He's, Geez, I guess you'd call
them a Vegan at this point.
He walked in and he started
telling me about hot dogs,
but the bags that are collecting the
stuff to make hot dogs. I'm like,
they're so delicious though. I'm like,
I'm like crowd a little mustard. I'm like,
I can't imagine that you would do
this. She's like, how to do it?
Had to go in there. I had
to see it. What's the,
it was just checking
how disgusting it was.
That was his job was just
go in there and inspect it.
I mean whatever their regulations are
for the kitten food inspection agency,
he was going in and taking a look at their
operation and deciding whether or not
this was acceptable practices and
whatever parameters that he's trying to,
you know, determine. So hot
dogs are like all like kneecaps.
It's pretty gross sticks and assholes
and stuff. False ground up together.
It's pretty shitty.
I can think of tastier things
that are less sort of disgusting,
but when you get them really good
ones, gourmet hot dogs, they suck too.
Like when you get like the,
those really nice ones that
snap when you bite into them.
I'm not going to turn around and try to
be the guy get sued by the hot dogs in
the street as well.
That's the last thing I did.
Now to those fucking hot dogs in New York,
man, those dirty hot dogs is Joey Diaz
calls him those just
setting up shop on a corner,
boiling some water.
I watched the guy and I dared him
eat five like Toronto dogs like this.
I couldn't believe he could do it.
I think shortly after we actually put a
cracker up to his mouth and open it in
weight because we thought maybe a warm
would come up because this was not right.
There's not a big guy. He pounded those
things. Couldn't believe Kobiashi guy.
The guy wins those eating contest.
He's not a big guy.
I had to pay for those hot docs.
Well, it's only five hotdogs, dude.
He had to pay with this shits and farts.
That's actually one has asked,
almost felt like in an
hour and a half late,
clinching it tight like it's his assholes
like a marathon runner and the last
couple of miles he did from it.
Get a pretty legendary story.
Not that good. It's not a good story.
You Canadians are much more [inaudible],
much kinder and what you judged to be
a good story. The story is sucked out.
A guy who ate hot dogs who gives a
fuck. We're so kind. We open pits up,
fill it up with whatever you want to
call it, if you want to call it water.
Everybody does that, right?
That's the problem. Yeah.
Well especially out in Europe right now
and other places, I mean not the UK,
they basically they,
they enacted standards of care that
were so difficult to abide by that it
eradicated the entire industry
in the UK, in the UK, the UK,
and this is what I tried to hope.
This is what I tried to get done here too.
It's like,
listen to dolphin can exist in captivity.
If you can't give it a 200 foot pool,
it's not economically viable or really
probably possible to dig a pit that big.
So guess what? If you can't abide
by it, you can't have dolphins.
This is the aspirations. These were
my aspirations. Um, then look at it.
It's gonna happen, but I don't
want to give up hope. I mean,
it should be illegal and we can't
really discuss it any further without
repeating ourselves over and
over and over and over again.
The bottom line is they're smart. We
should just talk about illegal, my loss.
Who should be too, like I right now
at the fact that we're talking now. I,
it's conceivable that I come home too.
I mean,
I know I'm going to come home to great
deal of really angry worded letters. Um,
because of you talking on
this podcast. Oh yeah. Oh Man.
You should see the shit that goes on now.
Who's saying sends you these angry
letters? Well, my Lord deals with it,
so he doesn't really tell him.
He just says these are from the people
in the opposition lawyer versus lawyer
camp.
What do they think?
They think that they could just keep
doing this and just scare people away.
It's trying to make me broke.
Yeah, it, I mean, it's working.
It cost me like when I get my bills,
they're not small.
These are like really big scary
bills like these or I could,
I could have bought half
a house at this point,
but instead pumping this
money into defending against
plotting to steal a walrus.
I mean, that's a peculiar thing
to, to, to defend against,
but it doesn't matter what I'm
defending against what it did.
Is that something they're accusing you of?
Oh yeah.
Will you actually plotting
to steal a walrus? Well,
if you and I sat here and said, Oh
man, we should steal that walrus.
What do you think is that
plotting to steal at Walrus?
I would say that's potty
then maybe I'm guilty.
But what they won't be able to
produce is a refrigerated, uh,
airplane cargo plane,
a beach front house in the Arctic
for her to live in this and that,
like plotting to steal the Walrus
is a bit of a stretch. Okay. Um,
so you were caught having conversations
where you're talking about, no, no, no,
not in the least. So based talk about
this. Oh, I can talk about this.
Absolutely. Okay. I think I
can, oh, there's smooshy there.
I mean if you want to go,
if you want to back things up under
that man, how fucked is that picture?
That picture Walrus is sitting
on a concrete floor with,
with her arm through,
it's a her right? Yeah.
With her arm through a fucking prison
cage. That's so dark, man. So the,
the story of smooshy is,
you know,
she come in from like wild caught
18 months of age, 200 pounds.
She's this big, he's a big
pillow. Beautiful Amy. She's
a baby. She's not good.
She didn't come in alone. She comes
up with some other animals, uh,
walruses where they catch
on Russia and the Black Sea.
So she comes in and we start then now
we've got to get blood from and we got to
see if these animals are healthy. So the
way you do it with an untrained animal,
you throw a big net on him,
physically jumped, grabbed them,
the fet sticks a needle in their vet or
train or someone and they go to take the
blood out.
Well,
during this procedure there was another
walrus there that we were doing the
procedure on and here's smooshy who's,
you know,
climbing up on the other walrus. It's
making things very difficult. He Mat,
as you can imagine,
these guys are like linebackers.
So all I did was I put my hands in front
of her face like this and she opened up
her nostrils and I, I remember this
vividly. She took a big breath.
She started to follow me. After that, I
started to back up this animal follow me,
big eyes staring at me, following me.
I've never seen anything like this before.
I thought it was like,
this is going to be just a onetime thing.
She just followed me because
this just made her nervous.
What had happened at 18 months of age
and at that specific time was I had
imprinted on her. That's what happens
in the wild. You're a mother, Walrus,
you shit out a calf that animal's going
to tattoo to its brain, your smell,
your sight,
the sound,
everything so that you can be
identified in a herd of hundreds.
This happened at 18 months of age.
So she imprinted on you,
just you imprinted on her because she was
panicking. I think it has to have been,
it was at that moment. And no
question because I know what the baby,
while this was all going down,
and you can imagine the stress of
being caught only maybe months before
separated from your mother or witnessing
your mother die in a harvest of source.
Jesus Christ. So this happens. So
this animal I imprinted on her,
well this is, this is an
anomaly. This doesn't happen.
This isn't, hey, here's food.
We're like best friends now.
Great. This is your mind, mommy.
That's the relationship we have. It's
crazy. Wow. Yeah, that's intense.
So then when you start factoring in the
fact that she's in the pool with a lot
of crazy chlorine values and she's getting
chemical burns and everything else.
And I'm like,
so you almost have a,
a paternal relationship with this?
Definitely have definitely
have a personal hours. Wow,
that's crazy. And all because of the
fact they're not cleaning the water,
she's getting sick.
Well there's more to it than that.
She come in at 2004 so she's probably 10,
a little over 10 years old now.
Um,
this relationship also turned into,
created some problems.
It manifested in like physical
manifestations of stress.
He developed this uncontrollable
regurgitating issue where
she doesn't keep her
fish down. She pukes it up and it's
from anxiety, from separation anxiety.
I'm fast forwarding a bit from that
moment of the imprint to now or, well,
it's a prior to now of course. So there
was, there was a lot of challenges that,
that relationship post.
So you try to train well,
so I developed this system where the
animal consumes fish and thereafter
consumed Jello. I would teach her to
eat the Gel and play with the Jello.
So try to keep her from throwing up the,
the nutrients that are keeping her from
gaining weight and being healthy. Right.
So I tried to train all the
other people on this, you know,
tried to wean myself out a
number of times. But again,
so the relationship was a blessing in
the fact that this is, this is amazing,
this is crazy.
And it was also an more so now like an
absolute curse because giving a shit
about an animal in that at that level.
Like what you're saying that that
parental, uh, relationship, that bond,
that's tough man.
Like to see what she's going through
and then you start realizing like,
I don't know what I can do to save
her because she's going to die.
Wow.
And she's back there at the same
place where you used to work still.
I can't be 100% positive.
She's still alive right now.
I did see a couple of videos in the summer
and those videos were tough to watch
cause she's still doing the same thing.
They don't really use her in the show.
She's well hidden in the back.
No one sees her.
They'll use her in the show sporadically,
but it's difficult to use it because
all she's doing is looking for me.
That's all she ever does.
She comes out and she looks for me.
Here was this video that come
out into summer. Sure. Shit,
I'm seeing she's and she's skinnier.
Fuck like
what?
What can I do?
There's another thing that's important
to remember. When I quit marine Len,
we had an understanding I was
to remain in this animal's life.
I live a football throw away from
this facility I gave my two weeks.
It's very clear
understanding she needs me.
Vets have expressed it.
Everyone knows it. She needs me.
That's the only way we could treat her
medically is if I'm there for her to
follow me out of the water to go over to
do whatever various treatments we were
able to do with her on
account of that relationship.
So we had this understanding and then I
was actually called in a couple of days
after I had quit to treat a
dolphin because it was not
a lot of experience that
was remaining at the
park to deal with this,
so the relationship seemed legit.
Okay,
I can move on as long as
I can keep her from dying.
I don't want her to die. Right then.
Then I had a conversation with a guy,
he had worked at marine land for
like 30 plus years. He was like,
he was up here to me. This guy was one
of the nicest men I know and he was like,
Phil, you just got to let go. Like
you know, just, just take a recess,
feeling a lot of anxiety about this whole
thing. Then I'd resolved. You know what?
I'm going to go. We ended the
relationship amicably. Marine Lana die.
I'm going to go visit smooshy.
It's been a month.
The longest I've ever not been in her
life since her arrival in 2004 it was 10
days. She lost 30 pounds over
that 10 days. This was a month.
Now I'm going to see smooshy.
So I show up to the park,
I get to the security gate to gate
that I walked through for 12 years.
Every day.
No one bats an eye.
Of course family here I'm
being rejected at the door,
like can't come in. And I'm like, what
do mean it can't come in? And we have,
we have that understanding. We have
like I'm still taking care of smooshy.
Okay, whatever. So I called my girlfriend
who's worked at the time in the park,
can you bring you one of my free
passes I got to pay to get in?
And the owner's son sees me, he grabs
me by the shoulders, says no, no Phil,
your like family here now you can come in.
Well unbenounced to him,
there's been some
something that happened
at the administration
administrative end where Phil
can't come in. The more it's time to,
there was a lot of concern when I quit,
but it was not good circumstances.
You might let go on a podcast.
I'm going to get sued for so
much more. Nonetheless, I get in
and people are really nervous,
so I know what's going on. I run back
to go see smooshy to the back. I say,
I run. That'd be better for
the movie. I don't think I ran,
but I'm trying to say nonchalant, but
walked back like we're smooshy, right?
I go see her and she's
lying on the pavement.
Bone dry Waller says need water
in the heat. They need ice.
There's no ice and site and she's lost.
This has been 30 days that I've been gone.
She's lost.
Okay.
Maybe hundreds of pounds. She's
really amazing at it. Whoa.
I'm looking at this like,
are you,
how much does she weigh total while she
should wait it around 2000 pounds now,
but she, at the time she
weighed maybe 12 again, she was,
she was a smaller animal and difficult
to keep the weight on because that
regurgitation issue, she was
weighing in real thin at this point.
I couldn't believe it when I saw her.
I'm like,
so first thing the vet does go get meds,
she'll respond to me.
So we give her her appetite, stimulants
and antibiotic. Everything else.
I'm trying to keep that
straight face like, Huh, walk
out. Like everything's cool.
Right. That night my girlfriend
comes home and she's like,
you know when you get hurt you don't. When
you're hurt, you're hurt by something,
but you know what it is so you
know that you're in a shitty place.
Okay.
The real pain is when you're hurting
so much that you don't know that you're
hurting. You're just sort of milling to
just sort of off the, you know you're not,
you're not in a processing that
she come home and she's like, Whoa,
what's ups? Nothing's up. Right.
Because on a few beers, whatever,
wasn't till the next day that I was like,
wow,
like she might, she's
going to die. I have to,
I have to come to terms with this reality.
This is fucked up.
That's when the resolve for me said.
I was like, fuck it. Use My name,
use my face, get the story out.
Now if I can get eyes on smooshy,
they got to take better care of her.
They got to do something. They can't.
Not People are going to
be paying attention now.
That's where it all lies on.
Smooshy if I got all eyes on smooshy,
they have the cat let her die.
But will she just die without you?
I mean,
if she's imprinted to you and
you are her mother, if he, if,
if she doesn't see you, will
she, will she die without you?
That separation anxiety again, I'd only
ever been apart from her for 10 days.
She lost 30 pounds. This her, that's her.
That's an inside edition piece that
was done years ago. Normous she's tiny.
So that's a tiny walrus right there.
Well, even a tiny Waller's is enormous.
My God,
they're so big.
This was a fluff piece that inside edition
did look at the size of our mind. God,
what a strange animal.
And these are all from the Black Sea.
She's from the black seat.
Yeah. Where else would they
live? Walruses um, I dunno,
they had them in the Saint Lawrence
in Ontario for a long while,
but they were hunted out.
So I dunno, I unfortunately,
I only ever played a bleed,
the marine mammal expert in life and he
will eat them. Yeah. People eat them.
Wow. Walrus. Yeah.
Walruses that's so strange, man. The,
the whole story is so sad
and disheartening. It's
so much more elaborate.
There's so many little details that
continue to go on. Like it's just,
so this is her following me.
She's calling for me here.
So I'm hiding around the corner and you
could see she's actually favoring her
left flipper.
That's where she had the chemical burn.
This is just prior to my quitting.
Really like just months.
But she had a chemical burn on her leg
that was so bad. I mean her limp. Yeah.
She's limping there because the
chemical out, I'll look at that.
She follow me anywhere.
That animal got to experience a semblance
of normality in the sense that I could
take her out, walk her
anywhere, walk around the park.
She got the guilt she has got,
she got to go in the snow. Right.
These walruses captive.
Walrus is such an indoor facilities.
They're never going to see the snow unless
you bring in the shovel full of snow
and it lasts 15 minutes.
So is it only Russia that's,
that's ganking these animals out of the
water right now that I know of. Again,
I can't,
I can't pretend to be an expert.
And it was only ever an expert in pretend
world for 12 years while I worked at
marine and propagated the messages
that I was fed. And now I can
admittedly say that I know absolutely
very little about animals between black
fish and the cove and you know,
things that are starting to shed light
on the treatment of these animals.
How much of an impact do you know how
much of an impact that cove has had on the
Japanese? There's the
heightened awareness, which you,
I guess you can measure its impact of
course. But politically there's a lot,
there's a lot of posturing going on there.
Japan wants to say that it's part of
their culture. They don't touch that.
But there's gotta be some financial
gain. There is something, I don't know.
I don't want, I can't weigh into that
as far as black shit, black shit,
black fish and everything
here. Like, yeah.
That awareness between the
star investigation, black
fish, everything else. Yeah.
People are starting to give a
shit now. Granted, it's nice to,
it's nice to experience in the
high levels of, you know, hey,
we're riding the high, I'm on the
Joe Rogan show. This is great. Hey,
people are contributing to my
Indiegogo fund. Hey, that's great.
Like we're going to
get through this thing.
There's a lot of Shitty freaking lows.
So this black fish one you want to say,
this is going to make for changes.
Everything's going to be eradicated.
Sea World's done. Look, problem solved.
It ain't that easy in six months.
No one's talking about this after it wins.
Maybe a fricking Oscar. Who knows? But,
and then that's it. I think it'll
be out there for quite a while.
I think it will be one of
those documentaries that
gets passed around on Netflix
or what have you.
As long as it makes its
way on the internet and a
downloadable form. That's a,
that's a pretty disturbing documentary,
man. This thing's a right hook.
I mean just like the star investigation
and realize it's a right hook so you
know that it's going to have
some sustained like influence
and change some power.
There's enough of this going on right
now that I think that people are,
they're going to have to
come to grips. You know, I,
I was hoping that about factory farming
too and I still am for the future.
I think there's got to be come a point
in time where there's so much information
out there that we can get ahold of in
relation to like how our food is being
raised, how animals are
being treated and how, again,
the animals that don't even want to
talk about is animals. The, these,
these marine wizards, he's Org orcas and
dolphins. There's something different.
They're not just a regular animal.
There's some weird superintelligent thing.
I think you'd find the same with a lot
of animals that were slaughtering and in
slaughter houses too.
But again,
I don't want to pretend that
I'm an XP and cows and takes,
especially if they're really smart, really
intelligent pigs, eat people, you know,
a guy got whacked off and not whacked
off, whacked out. What is it called?
[inaudible] and a Cecily. Um, uh, in,
in somewhere in Italy. I don't
know if was Sicily, but they uh,
they threw him in a fucking pen.
The pigs ate him alive.
So it happened on a western Canada.
Same thing. They found a farm and uh,
that was in Vancouver,
right?
A serial killer that was
throwing the hookers to the
pigs, feeding them, you know.
Yeah. They had to find like little pieces
of this and pieces of that and like,
hmm. They're thorough
when they eat. Yeah. Yeah.
Doesn't mean you've got to turn around
to hate him and like pound Bacon.
The Bacon Sandwich big is delicious.
You don't,
Higgs are not going to live forever.
I haven't eaten bacon a long time.
Picon was definitely the
thing that I wanted to wrap
everything in Canada. I did.
I backed, I wrapped ice cream.
Bacon. That's delicious.
Try it. I was curing bacon wrapped.
I took an Eggo waffle. I put,
I suppose you don't have to,
it doesn't have to be an Eggo
waffle and they put a waffle down.
I put a ice cream bacon,
another waffle. This,
this is when I do know what you're doing
by this story by not being a fat guy.
You fat shaming. Oh Shit. Here
we go. That's what I feel.
I feel he's fat shaming by being able to
say this, I can eat this. What about you?
You fat fuck with his shitty metabolism.
Just put one slice of Bacon instead of
the eight I put and then put and I put
the Maple Syrup, you know,
and then I put a little,
I can't remember like whip
cream or something like
pounding the same. I'm like,
wow, bacon an ice cream.
But now you're done no more.
You can just Guinea pigs
because they're intelligent.
Once you see what's going on there, you
can't unsee it. You can pretend to unseat,
but at night it reminds you, well,
especially pigs that are in captivity,
they're so sweet. Pigs in captivity
are like really gentle souls.
Pigs are strange animals,
man. They, you know,
I recently found out that pigs and wild
boars are essentially the same animal,
the exact same animal according
to this guy, Steve Rinella,
who knows a lot more about
animals and I ever will.
But he was saying that it's just,
we
don't know what that is. Yeah. What is
it? I've heard that before. It's off.
It's a funding page. It's the video.
This one is not difficult to watch.
It might be worth the watch though.
But what I was saying is that pigs
like wild pigs and domestic pigs are
essentially the same animal.
And one of the weirdest things about pigs
is when you take a pig, a domestic pig,
when they're released into the wild,
within three weeks, they start to morph.
They started to physically change.
Their tusks grow longer. Their nose,
their snout grows along
with their hair changes.
It gets thicker and courser they
did not come within three weeks.
They start the metamorphosis and then
become like wild boars starts to bother me
when the conversation comes in.
And the scientists,
at least those that are sponsored by
a bus or they're paid for by big money
start saying, oh, it's really difficult.
You can't re amalgamate
an animal with its family.
Can't put an of back in the wild. They're
used to this. It can't do it. Listen,
Orca is a kinetic, amazing machine.
Well, here's the real question.
How have they ever tried? They did
try. They tried with Keiko, uh,
free Willy Orca and it was successful.
This animal was taken into a sea pen and
then it was eventually off on its own
and it lived for a long time
and he would forge for food.
He interacted with other orcas.
He got intimidated by those orchids.
I mean it was probably a
little bit of a lonely journey,
but you've got to learn a great deal of,
of his life in the wild is reintegration.
And it was, it was a glaring success.
He did eventually die. Uh, but
nonetheless, I mean on all or,
cause eventually they all die. A lot of,
a lot of people like your your see will.
People are going to be like, well
he died. He died over there. Well,
how long did he live? I can't
remember exactly. Again, I can't,
I can't pretend to be an expert.
I read this,
I'll propagate this and
I'll tell you things,
but I don't think it has to do with the
longevity of how long you lived there as
much as the quality of life, but that
does sound like a scapegoat way of saying,
well,
he died early or
soon after buck. The wildest fucking
harsh man. It's harsh for everything.
Very few animals. You know what I was
talking about deer earlier when you,
you find a deer that's five years old,
that's a fucking old deer.
It's very rare that a deer gets to be
five years old and it's not just because
of hunters. It's because of predators
and freezing to death, freezing to death.
It's like the number one
cause of death for a mule.
Deer deer that live in Montana,
they fucking freeze to death, man.
Before the coyotes get them,
before anything happens, like shit,
it's cold as fuck and they're not going
to make it so they have to fuck like
crazy and shoot as many of them out there
as possible and hopefully a couple of
them will make it to next year and then
they fucked like crazy and keep going.
That's the only way or cause or
different man they like. I would,
I would imagine the ocean to be a pure
utopia. Pure and imagining, right.
I mean especially if they're in like
Alaska, they're the top somewhere.
They're top cheese.
They don't worry about anything.
They had dolphins that's lead anything.
They do kill dolphins.
It's Kinda fucked up. Fuck the
ORCAS. They killed dolphins,
but it's kind of fucked up. I mean
it's really kind of, that's one,
one of the weird things
about life is that it's the,
one of the major reasons why even Stephen
Hawking's has said that if there were
some sort of an alien invasion from an
intelligent species from another galaxy
or what have you,
we really should be concerned because
if we just look at the way we treat
animals that are lesser than us,
that we can control and look at the way
every other animal from chimpanzees to
monkeys to everything finds things in.
Either fucks it or eats it.
Everything's slower, are dumber
than it. It put it in prisons.
It fucks or at eats and that's what
we've done. That's what chimpanzees do.
That's what dolphins do. Dolphins
kill baby dolphins on a regular basis?
I don't know about that. They
do. They do come on the males,
the males try to displace
the cast for the females.
They get a pregnant yet super common.
Right? They're really horny though.
These are like peak times and Horniness,
right? It's okay to kill babies.
There's a,
there's a brief period where they're like,
well I mean or cause in captivity
are banging their daughters. Right.
That's that peak of of Supreme Horny.
This we don't know.
That's a big difference between that
we're talking about in the wild.
That's one of the reasons why female
dolphin promiscuity is so at such a high
rate.
I think we have to get worried if a
orchids grow legs because they're the ones
that are going on motherfuckers for
sure. I'm sure. Right? Fingers and legs.
They figured out how to wait to get
out of the water. We're done. My God.
Hopefully I'm on their good
side. Smart. An enormous,
if they could live in Seattle
where it rains all the time.
Just run through the streets
every time it was a rainstorm.
You got to bolt on your doors.
She's orchids are going to be running
through the streets looking to fuck people
up or cause they're nice though.
I think that you could probably like
it's the new shark Nedo like the new
Godzilla like baby Godzilla or go running.
Yeah.
Every time it's raining everybody
has a fucking bolt or door down.
Cause orkis they only need like six
inches of water and they start running.
They just need to be wet.
They don't even need a new water.
They did develop pause on their arm,
stretch out.
They just go into cocoons and then
they pop out with arms and legs.
It's better learn how to do back
flips for whatever you like to.
Yeah, but we have gun and shit.
I think it would be a slaughter.
They'd run down the street.
We just tagging them off,
but how many of them are,
they're really, we don't know
what's common bringing it bitch,
we don't know and the depths of the ocean.
They, we got jet son, we've got jets,
we can fly. We can fly and shoot
hellfire missiles down at town.
They're working on a factory
down there to come bring it,
come bring it a mental
fuck us the whole time.
Then all of a sudden we're
like putting guns on ourselves.
Probably are by being super sweet.
That's how they're mentally fucking us
by making us look like what piece of
shits we really are. I'll give a
shit now they're onto something.
They know what they're doing. Yeah. Well
I think, you know, as we said before,
I think that the more
the information gets out,
the more the reality of the situation
becomes into focus and not just for the
protected few that knew before but
couldn't do anything because you were
financially beholden to the one person
or people that own whatever organization
contains these animals and imprisons them.
And the reality of the situation as
it becomes more and more aware to you,
you know, as you go from being this kid
who's like got this great idea, like, wow,
I can't believe I'm here. Hold on
up. Killer whales TV. What a dream.
Two years later, like, Holy Shit,
I'm a part of an animal
prison or not even an animal.
I'm a part of an
intelligent things prison.
I can't feel a lot of
guilt for being there.
I didn't pluck them out of the ocean,
so I feel like maybe,
maybe I'm atoning for that
guilt of like shit man,
but doing a really good job in,
in the facility and trying
to care for the animals.
It's hard to feel guilt for doing that.
I don't think you should feel guilt.
I don't think guilt any good.
Right.
I mean the people that are
part of something or the
ones that are paying at the
gate, that's what needs to stop. Yes.
The only thing that guilt helps it.
Guilt helps you realize you're doing
something wrong, getting a bad feeling,
you realize you're doing something
wrong and hopefully correct it.
That's the only thing that guilt
really does. Other than that,
you know you haven't guilt for working
there, especially coming into it. No,
not knowing.
Being a young guy who had these idealistic
visions of what it was like to work
at a marine animals facility and trained
killer whales and Shit and then you get
there and you realize the reality of it.
Like that's just a part of, you know,
you realizing the world is complicated.
It's just, that's your version of it.
The overwhelming guilt was that I'm
not doing anything to stop this.
It wasn't an participating in this.
It's I got to do something.
Who's going to do something? I was
going to do something. Okay, fuck it.
Use My name, use my face Sumi for
millions. Get my girlfriend fired.
We're going to live in cardboard
boxes student. Great. Did you,
what's like when you went into this,
what was like,
what's the worst case scenario? If
you want, you just think about it.
Do you just think about it?
Like, did you like say, okay,
what's the worst that this can do to me?
What you wind up in jail when you wind
up in prison where you wind up in debt,
obviously. I wonder, yeah,
I guess the anxiety was like subside
of the great deal once the resolve was
there,
but that was only because I saw smooshing
like take that out of the equation.
I don't know that necessarily.
I would have at least had as as much a
hand in like allowing myself to, you know,
be a part of investigation.
He uses the name and face of course,
but that,
that guilt and everything else that fog,
you don't think rationally like,
well maybe I should just
back away and not try to,
to change the status quo because hey,
this could be at great risk. I mean,
of course, you know, you're going to
take a shit kicking, you know, you know,
you know there's going to be a recourse.
I don't care.
I don't want smooshy to
die. Right. You know,
you've gotta put yourself in their shoes.
It's like,
what are you willing
to do for this animal?
And I hate to call it animal, but this,
this being that you share this bond with,
what do you,
what lengths are you willing to go?
I decided I'm willing to stick my neck
out. Well, that's very admirable, man.
It really is. You know,
the, the whole mean you,
you're doing what the hero
does and the story, right?
And confronted with an inescapable
truth. You Act and uh, you know,
and especially emotionally in your case,
you being so attached to this one animal,
you know, literally it's mom to it.
That's gotta be a really strange time,
you know,
to know that you're right and know that
your instincts are correct and you're
acting on the best interest of the animal,
but it facing this intense
amount of opposition. It's mean,
it's classic hero story. I mean, I'm
just trying to get the happy ending, man.
You're obviously the good guy, good
guy, and every one of those stories.
I mean in that classic story,
you're obviously the good
guy. I don't know whether,
I mean you might be crazy. You might've
made most of this up. No fun up there.
I've done that.
[inaudible] telling me the shit.
We're going to play the video man, relax
this, this pacing man, he got, it's,
this is an art to this as
this is Hollywood man. I
would've, I know Hollywood.
This is fucking Canoga Park
sons is nowhere near Hollywood.
It's a long ways from Chippewa and
Niagara Falls. Well because it's warm out.
It's just a bunch of people. Dude, you
Canadians kind of get over that shit.
Scary place.
The states man and that,
I mean all of a sudden you come in and
you guys got like big roads and stuff.
Is that what it is? That big
roads coming out? Big Role.
Our books and big word cards are shiny.
They're not rusty either. It's amazing.
I'm looking around going,
wait, where's the rust?
Because you're used to people that
are traveling around with salt.
I had a jeep ratchet that,
yeah, when I lived in Boston,
every car had fucking big rust holes and
the quarter panels he could poke your
finger through right where
the wheel went. Yeah. Yeah.
Don't be cheap if you're in a,
if you're in Canada.
And what was the thing that
I heard about jeeps recently?
There was some sort of a, an issue about
recalls that, did you hear about this?
I didn't know. I was lucky to sell mine.
Actually. I, I made a deal with a guy,
he was like three k certified.
I'm like, yeah, no problem.
I look at certified for sure. I'd take
it to the shop guys like k hole here,
a whole here, this, that 4,000 of fixed.
I'm like, Oh man, I'm in deep shit.
And there there's a fuel tank.
Recall for jeeps, Bentleys,
Lamborghinis and Nissans.
Oh, this is like,
they're all being made by
the same place. Um, no, no,
obviously not. Right. Well, this
is what's confusing. The recall,
widespread recall jeeps to Lamborghini's.
So serious range.
Maybe they it was the same
tank or something like that.
I mean the type of tank I
could see you don't need
like a high end tank
to be in a Lamborghini,
although it would be a very
different shape. You know,
the different shapes for different calls
or just somebody who had brought this
up and I wasn't aware of it.
Some sort of a recall.
Icer says the trailer hitches will
protect the gas tanks which are mounted
behind the rear axle and are
vulnerable to rear impacts.
Although Kreisler told the agency that
a trailer hitch cannot and will not
mitigate the risk of high
energy rear car collisions,
but would incrementally improve the
performance in certain types of low speed
impacts. Boy, that doesn't make me feel
comfortable. The most hilarious shit.
Those those Teslas,
you know those Tesla ss,
one of the drivers is like a
big dolphin. A advocate. What?
Ilan Musk the guy because she's a woman.
Laelani Mun Munter there's a
lot of people that own them now.
They're pretty common, but they've
had three of them burst into flames.
I heard about that. Yeah, I apparently,
I mean it's a brilliant car. It's one,
many car. The years it's like
environmentally friendly. Well sort of.
Well that's the, I think they're pushing
that sort of sort of here's the issue.
They're all this conflict minerals in
every lithium ion battery when you're
getting lithium ion batteries,
if,
unless you absolutely are completely
sure of where that lithium was sourced.
You're getting lithium from Afghanistan,
you're getting lithium from the Congo,
you're getting lithium from some really
dark places where there's a lot of
people that are running the show that
are cunts and when you know when you,
it's one of the things about cell phones,
one of the darkest things about computers,
the very minerals that are used to run
your computer and your cell phones,
those are being pulled out of the ground
in certain places by essentially slaves.
They're being pulled out
by little kids in some way.
I mean maybe they've cleaned that up in
some places because this stuff has been
exposed,
but the Congo is notorious for being like
a really terrible place when it comes
to human rights.
Vice magazine has done several pieces
on the Congo and you know how it,
how it runs down there.
Like I saw like tourism piece of vice
magazine actually placed magazine wrote an
article on marina and that
still is the best damn article.
I mean they're the shit man. Oh yeah,
they're awesome. Oh, by the way,
I had Eddie Wong and Shane Smith or
coming back on together on the 18th.
It's going to be a party in here
and were told to bring booze.
So I don't see what happens.
But Eddie Wong and Shane Smith together,
Shit could be epic. Yeah. They'd go
everywhere and expose everything.
And you know what's beautiful about
vices that they have. Here's another one.
This is my favorite one though. The
electric cars, uh, they, the Fisker Karma,
those Fisker, you know, those things are,
those are those really beautiful ones.
They have a solar panel on the roof,
so the solar panel actually
charges up your radio and uh,
like your dashboard and you're
displaying everything like that.
It's like a supplemental
charge. Sure. Like, well,
well they're really cool
looking car, but they, uh,
they park them on the docks and during
the hurricane they fucking burst into
flames when they got wet.
I serious. Yes, yes. Yeah.
They fucking burst into flames, man.
You'd have that at least that tested like,
well, how was it when it's wet? Yeah.
I don't know. That's not good though.
Like what happened to that Porsche?
You know,
the one that Brian or that guy
from the movies died in? Oh,
the Carrera Gt Paul Walker died and
that's a very dangerous car, isn't it?
Yeah, it's a slippery
car. Um, Walter Role,
who is a world famous race car
driver, like he's been the, the,
the head test driver for Porsche
forever. You could see Walter role. Um,
you could see his, uh, his videos
of him driving all over youtube.
The guys who's super talented and
incredibly good at driving race cars.
And he got out of the career gt and
he was like, that car scared me.
This is a scary car. Too much power,
too weird with its handling. I mean,
it's a mid engine car. It's very dynamic,
incredibly powerful. 500 horsepower, very,
very light. And uh, he felt like at
the limit he couldn't figure out,
but he said they,
they drove it in the wet one of the first
times he drove it and he was terrified.
He said that the button,
the car needed two buttons,
one for the wet and one for the dry.
There's been quite a few accidents in
that car and including Jay Leno spun his
out at Talladega. He has a, he has
a Carrera gt, he has like, you know,
a hundred fucking cars, but he had
this Carerra gt spin out on him.
Jay Leno knows how to drive
fucking cars tire well as,
as this guy who was driving the car that
Paul Walker died and the guy was a race
car driver.
He wasn't just like a regular slow,
he really knew how to drive cars.
So I think it's one of those cars,
it's just super powerful and
like you have to really mind it.
You have to be really careful
of it. There's, you know,
there's certain cars that
they probably shouldn't exist.
Like the Mustang has a car out now,
Shelby gt 500 it has
670 fucking horsepower.
It's insane and I don't even
think it has 11 inch wide tires.
I mean they're not that
wide and this fucking thing.
I had the GT 500 from the previous years.
It had 550 horsepower.
It was ridiculous.
I couldn't imagine that someone had
that thing and said, do you know what?
This fucking thing needs another
hundred and 10 120 horsepower.
See the problem I have with these cars
and these these bikes is like if you
could like change the unused horsepower
though is probably you'll never use into
like value these vehicles that
are priced way. The hell up here.
I really only worth like you could pay
12,000 bucks for a Mustang because the
rest of the power that you'll never be
able to use or explore doesn't exist.
Like take it out of the
equation, you know? Yeah.
But who the fuck things like that.
That's one of the cool things about those
cars is that you have that power son.
Yes, you can. You get on the onramp, you
accelerate to 60 miles an hour
legally in three seconds. Well,
that's what I'm saying.
That's legal. Okay,
so within those three
seconds then there's value,
but there's still so much
unused potential. They're fun.
You're thinking like an accountant and
that's not what these cars are all about.
Especially cars.
Muscle cars are all about emotion.
It's all about the sound of
the rumble of the engine.
Even if you're not going fast,
like if you buy an old muscle car
that those things are terrible.
They drive like shit. They fucking handle
horrible. Every corner you go around,
there's no aerodynamics.
The breaks are dog shit.
Unless you upgrade everything
to modern standards,
you're dealing with a fucking disaster.
But it'll put a big fat,
stupid smile on your face when
you drive one of the stuff.
But these crotch rockets though,
I mean your first gear,
you're a half twist on the wrist
and you're, you're already like,
don't go through a school zone him.
He came and start this thing through a
school zone without giving up on the back
tire. Well, yeah, I mean
they're ridiculous. The
amount of power is ridiculous.
Nobody needs it, but people like it.
They like it. You know, California,
it's even scarier.
The bikes are even scarier than
the cars because they're so light.
It's such a small object that's hurling.
I remember going through a school zone
and it's like, I'm just blah, blah, blah,
blah, blah. On one of these
I've Katherine, it was like
a six or 900 something.
One of them up, up, up. I looked
down, it's like 70 clicks,
kilometers an hour in Canada. Holy
Shit. Like at least my license.
If I'm caught doing this,
I'm just going bump.
I'm trying to be as nice as possible.
Yeah.
They're so fast and you're so tuned in.
When you drive something
that's that fast all the time.
He's so tuned in to speed. You
know? You're so tuned into that.
All that crazy shit car becomes,
it becomes when it becomes an extension
of your body once you're in the zone.
Right. You gotta know your shit
though. Is that Jay Leno spinning out?
Did he hit the wall? No, it
looks, it looks like he hit
something man, right? Yeah,
he hit me.
Holy Shit.
Yeah.
Those are
what caused the splitter.
This,
they're fucking tricky cars, man. Just
like that. Just let it go. Just let go.
He was obviously turning.
You can see he's turning,
it'll hit the wall
when you drive in a car like that,
he's okay. He didn't hit the walls.
That would have said no,
I guess. No, I guess it,
it's a half a million dollar car too,
by the way.
I say they're probably worried
about the car too. Right? Well,
when you're driving a car like that, the,
the amount of traction that you have,
there's so much power and you're dealing
with the tires have to keep up with
what the engine can do.
Makes sense and you have to mitigate that.
You have to be able to balance
that out in a good race.
Car driver knows where the limits of the
tires are and also when you get onto a
track, the tires aren't at their peak
immediately. You might need five,
six laps warm to warm up the tires so
you get to get to the temperature of the
tires is very critical to performance.
Especially when you're dealing with like
cop tires and these fat slicks that a
lot of these race car
drivers drive around on.
So the whole deal is about putting heat
into those tires and until you have that
or if the conditions are bad or if
it's rained within the last 48 hours,
all those have big factors on the amount
of traction that you have on that,
not to think about and getting behind it.
That's nice. Nice thing about the jeep.
It's just bup, bup, bup,
bup, bup, bup. Mean.
Obviously we were just talking
about race cars. Most cars,
these things don't come into factor,
but what does come into play is that
the lessons learned from these cars,
these cars going really fast around race
tracks. People think it's ridiculous,
but why would you need that? Why
do you, you don't, you're right,
absolutely shits and giggles. This sport,
it's for shits and giggles. It's a hobby.
It's a pastime.
But the lessons learned from these races
are exactly why today's cars are so
safe that today's cars handles so well.
They're so aerodynamically sound there.
There,
there are zero to 60 times have
dropped steadily every year.
It's all because of the improvements
that they made because the motor sports,
like if you look at like Porsche has um,
they have a Panamera,
you know what that is? They have
a four door car, they have a big,
it's like a big like Mercedes looking
thing, big spaceship looking thing.
I've seen like the, I've seen like
the, they've got to almost an SUV.
Look at Porsche, that's a Cayenne. They
have those cars that they have now.
They fucking defy physics. These things
are insane. When you drive one of them,
the engineering involved in
these 500 plus horsepower,
twin turbo,
5,000 pound vehicles or whatever the fuck
they way it's well over 4,000 pounds.
It's,
it's shocking when you drive,
you can't believe how they handle
all that's from motor sports.
All that's from the lessons they learned
in engineering and trying things out,
doing things like, you
know, like 24 hour races,
the little Oman's races and all the gt
races that Porsche gets involved in.
They learn all that.
They learn from those mistakes.
And how to improve those fast cars and
then the apply those lessons to their
regular cars,
their consumer cars,
and they also apply it more so or at least
a great deal on the shits and giggles
factor because that's what, that's
where they're getting off. I mean,
making these things big.
It doesn't address a lot of people's like
I'm never going to drive one of these
things. Yeah, it's awesome that that
guy could, I can't drive that. Well,
they're getting,
they're getting a Nunes insane levels.
Why don't just put wings on these
things. They're flying. They can't,
that's not legal yet,
but when you get into,
when you start talking about like a
performance levels like zero to 60 levels,
like just 10 20 years ago,
if you get a car to zero to 60 in
four seconds would be crazy. Like wow,
zero to 60 in four seconds. You could get
that in a Mustang gt. It costs 35 grand.
I mean a regular car that you buy can
Mustang gt almost a zero to 60 in four
seconds. It might be like four or five
at the most, half a second slower.
It's crazy. The performance. They've
got a [inaudible], a Porsche, um,
uh,
the turbo s the nine 11 turbo s the
new one goes zero to 60 in 2.7 seconds.
Where do you have to be in to
take 2.7 seconds to get, I mean,
that's great for fireman. I don't want
to say police necessarily, but you can't,
obviously it's tough to get
fire gear in a Porsche nine 11,
but what's going to be, what's going
to happen in a hundred years from now?
Is it going to be zero to 60 instantly?
Are we going to like warp thread?
It's going to be at different means
of transportation altogether. Really?
Look what, yeah. Wormholes. Like you say,
I dunno what transponders
with the Pipi gone. Yeah.
I guess if we never saw
the internet coming,
we're not going to see the next thing
coming either. You know, evolution,
everything's evolving.
Where I'm holes in your car,
you're going to press a button, you're
going to show up in the office right now.
The fastest way to get somewhere
to keep shit at though all
got to work from home now boom,
so you have a 60 I think the fact that
you could send files through the mail,
through email,
you could send files through online.
Drones are now going to
start dropping shit off.
You're not going to have to go
to that many places anymore.
I think actually physically going places.
I think we're going to be trapped
at home looking at monitors all day,
talking to each other,
face to face through these things.
Can 99% of my friends already.
Where do you think this,
this whole controversy and lawsuit, where
do you think this takes you? Do you,
do you have like an end game here?
Do you have like a an escape clause?
Do you have like a way that
you can so get out of this,
it's a slap suit to strategic
lawsuit against public participation.
The idea is he launches the suit. I
shut the hell up. The suit goes nowhere.
He had their backs at the hell
off or he bleeds me dry phone.
I got, I'm out of funds. I don't
get a choice in the matter.
I signed a piece of paper saying,
I'm not going to bother you in more.
I'm never going to talk.
And if somebody wants to Google your
whatever it is to Gogo, what does it save?
smooshy.com save smooshy.com
so I'll smooshy you should
probably smell smoke a s
M o. O. S. H. I. So this is
the fourth campaign that we've,
that I've launched.
I've basically raised about $40,000 and
then there was that Billy challenge that
I think you spoke to Les Stroud a boat.
Yes. Less speaks very highly of you,
which is why you're here. Thanks
les. Les is a great guy and he's,
he's an awesome guy. He's my homeboy
last one. A long ways to try to help us.
We won through less.
We won $32,000 Canadian one day.
I'm sitting there talking about initiating
payment with the guy like, okay,
we're flying this guy or this
guy guy's being flown down.
We're going to have a big presentation.
Less is going to be
there because you know,
les was the celebrity that was sponsored
to our charity and then a week later
I'm reading that this Billy challenge
his belly up and simple as that,
but by no money, what? Like 32,000 bucks.
I'm trying to support three lawsuits right
now. Mine, my girlfriend, I'm confused.
What happened? They disappeared.
They don't exist. There's a website,
the [inaudible] dot com you hit it.
They've suspended operation.
We're not getting paid. Oh, so they quit.
They went under. They bailed in there.
Something happened. Okay. We
don't know what, but I tell you,
that's a shitty day when you wake up. I
mean the emotion where you're like, shit,
we're being supported big time.
We just went $32,000 that's going to
see me till next summer. Beautiful.
Because the longer I can sustain
this battle in these lawsuits,
especially with the counter suits,
there comes a point where the,
with the power swings,
he's trying to,
they're trying to beat the snot out of
us in every which way they can using
money.
If we have that money and we last so long,
suddenly they have to start disclosing
files in our lawsuits that they do not
want to disclose. The objective
is bleed 'em dry, drop the suit.
They've done it this historically. That's
the, that's the function of a slap suit.
If I got the monies and
I get so far, oh, oh,
black fish,
the movie,
everything that was revealed in there
was from the Osha versus seaworld, uh,
trials.
All the stuff that see had to give,
they have to provide video of orcas
beating the snot out of trainers. Uh,
you know, a bunch of all these things come
out. It's the same thing with, with the,
with marine land,
they're going to have to open up
files about the killer whales health.
They're going to have to open up files
and what a lot of things exonerating us.
They're gonna have to show the water
log histories, the, the newspaper.
It has that. But nonetheless, they're
going to have to disclose these things.
They don't want to do that.
Their objective is sue the shit out of us.
Make us broke. Drop the suit. Go.
That was the way of the nineties
eighties seventies whatever.
It's a new day and age.
Suddenly there's a Streisand effect.
You Sue me to shut me up, blows up
the whole thing. It blows it right up.
Everyone's listening.
People give a shit.
I wind up getting enough money to see
this thing through. He can't drop it.
I got the counter suit while let's
start opening books. You want to see,
you want to have a look inside.
Let's start opening books, you know,
and it doesn't. Opening financial
books, finding out how many profiting,
medical records, water
log history, how did,
how much did you pay for those dolphins?
Let's find out like whatever. I mean,
there's a bunch of things
that apply to the losses,
but moreover there's also the question of,
Hey,
if you're a person that's
going to turn around and say,
I don't think animal abuse is cool and
you wind up being sued, made, broke,
wiped out, that's not a good precedence
to send for people out there.
It's not good for the human race.
It's not good. It's precisely at,
this is less about, I mean
it's about animals primarily.
Initially, this is social,
social justice.
So what you're essentially doing is
reaching more people than the people who
have influenced, can reach with
their money and their influence.
They've collected a bunch of people
that are controlling the regulations and
enforcing the laws and they figured out
a way to keep these people under their
wing. But what you're doing
by getting on this podcast,
by starting your India Gogo count and
fucking being one of the Gogo girls or
whatever,
what you're doing is spreading
that passed their reach of control.
He's got money. They only have
a little bit of money though.
They don't have that much money. How
much money is, yeah, he's got a billion.
He's got to have a lot more than me.
This is a fucking 300 million
people in this country.
If you get $1 million of
those people find out I sleep.
How much money does he have?
Really? And by the way,
if you start fucking organizing
a boycott of his property,
that money goes away ultra fast.
While the numbers are down bad,
they fucking should be,
man. It's a prison colony
at the monies. I sleep easy. Again.
I took this thing on. This wasn't,
hey,
for the next 80 hours,
every fucking week you're going to go
petition the shit out of trying to get
people's money. That sucks. Asking
for people for money really sucks.
What the hell else am I supposed to do?
I've been pinned.
I've been backed into a corner. I'm coming
out swinging. I got to do what I can.
It seems to be working.
We're getting somewhere that anti slap
legislation that was announced in Ontario
that's coming. If that aunt anti
slap comes sooner than later,
we're in a race right now like anti slap,
meaning that it stops these kinds
of legal lawsuits that's happening.
I think it's in it's second reading
and Ontario legislation like,
and this is all because of the lawsuits
that were, that were launched against us.
There's, there's a lot of attention,
so suddenly they're getting nervous,
so they're really pushing this agenda.
They're trying to,
they're trying to get me to pony up for
this motion to strike out everything.
In our defense. Everything
in our counterclaim lawyers
are us. 15,000 bucks a pop.
I got three lawyers. I'm trying
to support mine, my case,
my girlfriends and this nice man who
worked for 12 years who spoke about the
time the owner shot two pets,
golden retrievers on his,
on his, uh, on his property
and marina property.
They went and sued him for telling
them, wait a minute, wait a minute.
What did he do? It's deep. He
allegedly, I was there that day.
I can attest that a lot
of things that happened,
these dogs come running in these two
pets. Golden retrievers, golden labs,
golden retrievers.
Well he doesn't want them there to more.
They're running up and down the
fence there bothering the deer.
He shot the day here. Two
shots. I come in to work.
Someone's out there doing his thing.
Phone rings. What's this guys name?
John Holder. He's the one who shot
these two golden retrievers allegedly.
Whoa.
So the guy who was very brave to say that
and have other stories where he had to
do some really had them do some really
tough things is being sued as well.
Whose dogs with these? The neighbors. One
of the low, one of like two houses down,
so the dog's just got out of the yard
or something like that out of the yard.
Barking started into the parking lot
because the right across the street is the
deer park. Gates Open. Dogs
start in Shit. My dogs are gone.
Boom, boom. There's witnesses. Whoa.
Well had these dogs at tag the deer where
they just, oh well. I mean, I don't know.
I wasn't there for that, but
nonetheless, I mean, fuck you,
don't you don't you just call the Osp,
say come get these fucking dogs. The labs.
You come grab me, go, come here buddy.
They're the sweetest dogs on earth.
Told you off the hop. Don't try to
rationalize his thinking. Everything.
It's a good idea is a bad dude. Golden
labs are just the sweetest dogs ever.
I've never met a single mean one
in my life. That stories out there.
The videos are a shitty poodles.
Every golden lab I met wants to give
you a kiss when you get close to it.
Those things are gems there. They're
beautiful dogs. That star investigation,
if you go to this, the Toronto Star
website and just look up Marineland,
there's probably three dozen stories
and that's in there. Yeah, boom.
He's how never get that web.
Well,
that's harsh shot neighbor's
dogs. Yeah. Wow. Oh my God.
I heard these stories.
There's,
there's a shit ton and it wasn't just
the three of us that are being sued.
It's a bunch of people. He's suing
an activist for one point $5 million.
This guy come out of nowhere. There's
the dog. So that was the dogs. Oh my God.
There's actually video of the dog.
Very playful, beautiful freaking dogs.
Their fucking pants. Well
now they're dirt. Oh God.
What an asshole. So what happened
out of this? But he got sued. Yeah,
but he's getting sued.
Who's getting sued?
So the night I was out of pocket $5,000
someone's going to retain a lawyer for
this man. Who's going to do it. I'm
looking around and shit. I buddy,
you're talking not talking about it on
whole or you're talking about your friend
who got in trouble for this?
Talking about the guy who right,
who came out about this and then
started to sleep easy at night.
Decided to say look,
cause he,
he quit about six months
before I did amidst really,
I mean if you think the
marine mammals got it tough,
you should see the land animals
at this place. It's real tough.
Some really shitty things going on.
What do you mean land animals? Marine land
has landed on his own. It's own entity,
man. They have bears. What? Oh yeah,
they have bears should read about
the bears. That's a shitty story.
I fucking hate bear captivity
man. There's a video, Brian,
I want you to pull this up. Bear
kills man. And like eight seconds.
There's a video that I,
I refer to whenever anybody talks to
me about bears being trained and people
training bears and pull up the video.
Brian have a bear,
a kills man and fucking seven
seconds or whatever it was.
It was the bear from a movie. I forgot
the move. I want to say the longest shot,
but it wasn't the longest yard.
It was like first and Tan or some fucking
football movie or something like that.
There was a bear in that movie.
A trained bear is Baird worked in
Hollywood and films and TV shows,
his cousin or brother or something.
He's having the guy stand
there while he's trained.
The bear cause happens for real and the
bear just attacks the guy out of nowhere
for no reason. He's a barrier.
Just exactly launches. It's out.
This is it right here. This is
terrible. I can tell you right now,
looking at that bear, I can
tell you this. Trouble brewing.
The guy's standing there and he's just
doing nothing and the bear just decides
to fuck him up and that's it. It
should turn away. Turn away, Brian.
I want to see him. Shit. That's the
end. He ripped the guys, throw it out.
The guy was dead in seconds. You can't
fuck with bears, man. They do what?
They want. Their bears. Same as killer
whales, man. Same as any animal there.
They're wild.
It's not a golden lab.
A golden lab is not a wild animal
by any stretch of the imagination.
Two shotgun shots all took man. That
the details in those stories. Uh,
you know, when Jim quit, I was
the day that those, uh, those,
those dogs got shot.
I actually got pissed at Jim because
I was in the office with the vet.
The vet gets a call. She's like, what?
Oh my God. Puts the phone down. She like,
fuck the owner of just shot two
retrievers are golden last. I'm like,
fuck. They're like, well, you
know, Jim wanted to do this,
but he didn't. I was like,
fuck man. I was pissed at gym.
In my mind, I'm like, Jim, quit.
Surely after Jim was in a real tough
spot. Jim Speaks brave as hell. Man,
I'm so proud of this man. He's the
nicest, gentle man you've ever met. Boom.
He slapped to the fucking lawsuit.
So while, who's going to pony up?
I was out of pocket. I start fundraising
out of pockets are fundraising,
but that's the idea. They keep
launching suits. We can't keep up,
but at some point, man can't
keep launching them. Ontario
govern paid attention.
Can't do it. No more anti
slap legislation. It's
coming. But we're in a race.
We're in a race because they're
pushing these different things.
There's an activist, as I was saying,
and his name's Mike Garrett. He was,
he read the star articles in the newspaper
about everything that's going on.
He's like, what the fuck starts
holding the sign up there.
Danny brings out a bull horn. Then he
starts interacting with the owners.
It's a video there. That's amazing. You
want to see the owner of marine land?
He uh, he starts like, he's actually
threatened to stab the guy on video,
which is crazy.
And the fucking Susan,
he sues him for a bunch of Shit. That
never happened. It's all bullshit.
It's a slap suit. It's just, hey,
if you keep talking and
telling the truth about us,
we're going to sue you to
shut you up. Well, that's,
now that's more so what I'm advocating
for, this is a social justice issue. Now,
you know, so I keep making a
stink, but at the end of the line,
there's always smooshy.
I still have dreams, man.
I still want to see what that animal,
I know what she's going through.
Of course I need to see her. So is this
what's turning you into a vegetarian? No,
it's, you know what it is? It's
so on Twitter. On Facebook.
Like people are following me.
Right. And they're always, you know,
I follow people or I got shit on Facebook
and there's always these fricking
images and I'm like, ah. Right. It keeps
seeing him keep seeing him. He can't,
like I said, you can't unsee.
You don't, it doesn't take long.
You only got to watch 30 seconds of
one video would be like off, off.
I don't need that no more.
That's, that's out. I like cheese.
I have a real tough time
getting away from cheese,
like really old thin
slice chai for cheese.
They suffer like you would not imagine
at the end. They do in the worst ways.
Milk, milk. I'm off milk. Wait a minute.
But what about natural organic milk
where they just go in and milked the cow?
I'd have to see it.
I'd have to see it to know,
but I know the milk that I was drinking
and the gallons is done. I'm out.
I see what you're saying.
So the factory farmed milk,
the way they get it on the standard,
I don't know what percentage
of what you buy at the store,
but a great deal of it is cruel at
you that you cannot imagine. Ah, dude,
why you bumming me out now? Welcome to
my world. Every time I log into Facebook,
boom, milk cows shitty. Especially now
that you're connected to that. Well,
all these people have befriended,
they're all supporting and they're all
doing their costs. You know, I wanna,
I wanna help.
I wanna see what we were talking about
earlier about the broad spectrum of human
behavior that people can be kind and
sweet and people can be fucking murderous.
Cons.
There's,
there's this spectrum and unfortunately
that manifests itself in business as
well.
And the way we treat animals as far as
factory farming and as far as running
these marine animal facilities
or zoo. Moreover, the,
the people that are working
at these places, yeah.
They got to earn that of course.
And not only that,
they probably like you went into it
with good intentions and along the way
realize what it actually was. You
start when you, I mean, you got to,
you got to pry open that third eye.
You've got to sort of
get yourself out of the,
out of the element itself and look
from a different perspective altogether
cookie and go to the zoo. Uh, I
would definitely advocate for that.
Let's play that video and uh,
I gotta take a leak.
So let's play that video
and I'll come back while, so
you still have it? No. Why would you?
You're going to see the dog video,
the video that he was going
to play earlier. Oh, this one.
The only way really to do Marineland or
to do a story like Marine Le Pen is to
have an insider or somebody who's just
left and worked inside a long time.
And I never thought that I
would be able to get somebody.
And then when I did,
I thought that the story would probably,
I would be on it a couple of weeks,
maybe a month, it would be some digging.
And we're almost a year later.
It just kept growing into different
stories and his different government
departments got involved.
It just went on and on.
I mean there a period
where either myself or,
or with another photographer
or with Liam Casey,
we lived on the road between here and
Niagara Falls in May of 2012 I got a phone
call from someone who said that there
was a lawyer who was talking to somebody
who had worked at marine land and talk.
This person had some issues with marine
land and wondered if I wanted to talk to
them.
It was really difficult.
And finally in the end he
decided he would talk to us.
And that was filled in Maris,
the first whistle blower.
Over the course of my tenure at marine
land, I was witness to things that
people would never imagine a place
like marine pen to be capable of.
In the end we were working with
15 whistleblowers and it was, um,
they're feeling that problems that had
existed with the water not being able to
get the low levels raid had caused
health problems in the animals.
And also short staffing
had caused problems
cause we didn't have the resources,
we didn't have the people to
get the animals to do these certain tree
behaviors that we would otherwise want
them to do. The first line of
defense was to give him the drugs.
I saw things that that resulted in death.
You're basically hitting your head against
the wall trying to make changes for
the better for the animals. And one
day I walked in and walked out, uh,
just said,
that's enough.
Oh there was a huge reaction from the
public. I mean, a massive reaction.
My email was jammed.
I think we got something like 270,000
views on the video and the first day the
OSP CIA issued orders against marine
land on a number of Caribou mainland.
Completed all orders from the,
but what was also interesting
is that the government reacted,
the Minister Medlin mayor is
bringing in a program one,
it's her hope to license
zoos and aquariums in Ontario
because they're not at
this time.
The second thing will be special standards
of care for marine mammals because
there's nothing and the
third will be greater powers,
more money and greater responsibility and
also hopefully Trent more transparency
for the OSP.
Ca Three of the trainers who
spoke to me and have been sued,
these are generally slap suits which
are basically to to shut them down,
but still this hootsuite for
I think a million, 1,000,001.
They haven't gone to discovery or
anything yet and I know they have a lot of
supporters. When I did these stories
and Liam and I worked together,
we were writing about the animals.
We had no desire and have no desire,
just shut marine land down or anything.
There's that Mr. Holder
has been saying it butters.
All we wanted to do is tell people,
we went to marine land,
we talked to people,
we interviewed people who've worked there.
We've looked at records, we've looked
at video, and here's what's happening.
That's all. And I hope that they're able
to make them much better. Marineland
yeah, he sued, he sued the trial
starts to really chat. Amazing.
What'd he sued them for?
Um,
I don't know exactly their sort of tight
lipped at that end. They don't, you know,
that they're not going to reveal too
much, but the matter of fact is, uh,
the Toronto Star or any media, you
know, they get a suit. Did you know,
in the room of these places, demand
an apology if there's been a mistake.
Sometimes they just, you know, there's
a little little money paid out.
Something else starts fighting this
completely. They're like, yeah, let's go.
Let's do this. Well, we tweeted it. Uh, I
just tweeted it about 10 minutes ago. Um,
and uh, I'll tweet it again and
we'll promote it on this podcast and,
and try to get some people to
contribute some money to help out your,
your legal defense.
And my thing is I don't need,
I don't need a lot from you and he,
a lot of you,
she knew a lot of people don't we five
bones, man, we can get through this thing.
And the other thing is,
you know,
there's reality TV out there
and people obsess over it.
They can't believe that this scripted
bullshit. I mean, you know about it.
I know about it.
I was on the TV show white bone.
I know about sort of the scripting
and things you were on wipe out.
I was on white folks. My friends
show Mac units. I was going to say,
because I think it was shortly after a
fear factor that they went with the wipe
out. Yeah. It's end them
all. Yeah. He created it.
Wild wild fear factor was going
on, right? Yeah. Yeah. We've,
we've been over there
many times like that,
that place where they filmed it in
Argentina or an la? No, they only one.
The one I see me when I did the Canadian
version that they basically sent this
to Argentina. Oh really? Yeah. Yeah. They
do like they do it all over the world now.
Right. And bunch of different
countries and they all go to Argentina.
I think the states is the only one
that has like a really amazing course.
That course is awesome. It's evolved quite
a bit. The one that Argentina is like,
it's pretty bad ass like
donkey Kong and shit.
Just like metal rods everywhere like
that. She's real. Yeah. It's nasty.
It's a fallacy. It's a fall
course. So you got mistreated.
Much like the animals get mistreated.
His fucking,
that's the theme here on the show. Yeah.
I won though. Oh, congratulations. Thanks.
That's awesome. That's bad ass.
I owe it all to smoosh. Yes.
The only reason I was ever on the video,
right.
You were doing it to try to earn some
money? No, just the, uh, back in 2008,
that was like the meat immediate
shitstorm that took off.
Like Jimmy Kimmel did a piece,
like inside edition did a piece of,
it was like a fluff piece of smoosh
and i's relationship, but it took off.
It was on the cover of CNN for awhile.
And so I just sort of pieced all that
together and applied to wipe out and was
like, Hey, I'm this guy. And they
were like, hey, you're on. It's okay.
So I'll go do that and try to
win money. Wow. Well listen man,
I hope we help. I hope we helped
raise awareness. I thank you.
You did a great job of representing
your position and representing the,
the idea behind what you're trying
to do and the situation that you find
yourself in. And I think it's very
admirable and I think, um, that, uh,
I think you're going to get a
lot of sport. I hope so, man.
I really appreciate your letting me come
out here and it was fascinating, man.
It was really interesting. I really
appreciate you having the balls to do it.
Well, balls, idiots. See Christmas,
call it part of being a person, Ben.
Then the future, they'll look back on
it and say it's balls, but right now,
whatever you just doing your thing, man.
Tweet that shit man. I tweeted it already.
Thanks man. And uh, we'll uh, we'll tweet
it more in the upcoming weeks and uh,
just get in contact with me and if you
have more things you need to promote,
we'll be happy and really happy to have
you come on again and give us an update
in a few months and tell
us where things are at.
Like I was saying reality TV or pay
for this, I mean this, it's developing,
it's staying on the front pages. So, well,
you could get a reality TV show just
because of this interview that's in the
lawsuit. I can't, you can't. Well, in the
lawsuit and the lawsuit they're alleging,
I'm really pissed off because why
couldn't you get a reality show up?
A couple of reality shows were
proposed to me after wipe out, right?
And in the lawsuit they're
saying, oh, these reality shows,
that's why he's really mad
and making up these lies.
And they went through all this shit up.
That's how I became the Kanye west
of animal training. They say that,
but don't say that. Stop you just filled
dimmers. Stop this Kanye West. Bullshit.
That's gotta stop. It's gotta stop.
It's stupid. Uh, but the, the,
what I'm wondering when she was about
is how could they stop you from doing a
reality show? How can they
prevent you from earning a living?
How can they stop you from expressing
yourself in any way that you choose to see
more?
So it's the sense that with all these
lawsuits and no one wants to touch it,
no one wants to touch anything. Right? I
think that's nonsense. People in America,
I guarantee you will touch it. Hey,
we had an article that was going on,
a very big magazine,
a very big man cause he was coming up,
was going to tell the Fillon and smooshy
story. This thing was going to be,
I mean this was godsend.
They manage to quash that it's gone.
They won't do it because the lawsuits,
there's dudes scrambling right now writing
your name down. Trust me. This is a,
this is with a in America, here's what
matters on reality shows, ratings,
how many people are watching. If a lot
of people were watching it gets on TV.
It's that simple, but it's the money
generated doesn't support a lawsuit.
Then what?
I suppose Canada is a different story.
I mean we're not talking about if the
money generated from what? From a,
from a reality show show, which you
can start balancing port a lawsuit.
In what way?
Well,
I don't know if someone launched a TV
company turns around and talks to me, hey,
we want to talk about,
we want to do a suit or a show
about you fighting a marina marina.
She gets immediately sue them,
immediately sued them so that
TVs coming like thing like that,
like universal pictures or something
like that is afraid of morale.
I haven't got the call from them, but if
they call, I suppose maybe they won't.
But a lot of people have been scared.
A lot of people have been scared.
So you alleged that they've been scared
off of doing other reality shows?
There were, she were to say
that there were two. Listen,
not that maybe it's probably
not a good thing. Well,
we know that it's slapped litigation,
so it's all bullshit anyways.
I'm pretty sure they're done.
Let's not bullshit is the cause.
It's a great cause and I think,
uh,
I think this and the movie blackfish has
highlighted a real problem that we have
is there's a real disconnect with the way
we view these animal parks and I think
they're fucked up. And
I turned this man. Yeah,
awareness is important and
the conversation is important
and I'm glad you got it
out there. We lost that 32,000
bucks, but on the flip side, boom,
I'm on the Joe Rogan show and blackfish
come out. I'll trade that all day.
There you go. Boom. Bitches respect.
All right. Thank you to our sponsors.
Thanks to audible.com go to audible.com
forward slash Joe and get yourself a
free audio book and 33
days of audible service.
Thanks also to stamps.com
use the offer code, J r. E.
When you click on the old school,
he microphone in the upper
right hand corner of the page,
the offer code jre gives you a no
risk trial and $110 bonus offer,
which includes a digital scale
and up to $55 of free postage.
Thanks also to [inaudible]
dot com. That's o, n N.
I t use the code named Rogan and save
yourself 10% off any and all supplements.
We'll be back next week. We got a
lot of people coming up next week,
including Mike Birbiglia and
cliffy be in the same fucking day.
We'll your Dick not explode.
We've got a lot of other people.
Got a few standup Comedians
I got working in and a,
we shouldn't have a good time.
And then next weekend I will see you
guys at the crest theater in Sacramento
with the lovely and talented long,
long La Tony Hinchcliffe. Um,
I'll be at the laugh
factory tonight at the dom.
I rarely show and Friday night I'll
be at Thunderpussy at the ice house,
which is a show where I guess how's
it go again? Uh, you can get on stage.
People from the audience get yelled at
a topic and you just try to do stand up
about that topic on the spot.
Sine I've been doing that since the eight.
I know you're going to be a professional
that's called being stoned on stage.
That's fucking par for the course. All
right. Uh, thank you Phil and Phil.
People want to reach you online
filled dimmers on Twitter.
D M Twitter is walrus whisper. I kept
the moniker, so walrus, Walrus, whisper.
While we're [inaudible] find me,
I suppose if you want to go there,
but build dimmers,
d m u r s t e m e r m e
r s and safe solution,
m e r s Phil,
d e m e r s a and save smooshy.com.
Thanks brother.
Really appreciate you being on. Thank
you. All right, we'll see you soon.
Freaks big kiss.